[Music]
n
he
[Music]
n
new
Challenger welcome to the next battle t
and eight new
Challenger
Marshall I love
her shout out to the queen of the realm
the Tekken realm lady Lena heart
hopefully working on something for y'all
with that in the future for my my fgc my
fighting game Community how my levels is
sounding trying to wake up a little bit
little tired y'all little tired trying
to wake up what's going on young Dre
what's up I saw that uh that joint the
um the Jazz and fil um art that was that
was dope off the fly I like that what's
going on Zach Zack Riley what's going on
lyan mass what's going on shout out to
the OG Gerald M Bay Area all held the
ILP # great gears have a real love
gaming you new dude should try it love
the hob salute The Gamers yes yes yes
yes Craig Hol again I see you what's
going on appreciate the m message
gorilla 1 no doubt doy opal all right
all right all right you got bars for Tim
Stewart okay Mayan five what's going on
you already know salute salute all right
all right anime
compilations Doctor Strange Love relax
yourself graphic God what's going on the
gamer Peg Master the artist himself the
legendary the Lord of emotes the Lord of
get go see him if you need work done
that man's official he's professional we
doing a long time great to see you
graphic art you already
know living God what's going on Sinister
what's going on brother I've been so
tired this week me and you got to catch
up man I know I got that new dungeon to
do it's crazy it's crazy Dante what's
going on salute
salute y want that beefy y' I was messy
in the patreon I think I know what y was
doing yes yes there we go go go support
that y'all Xbox gamer.com you like the
graphics you like what's going on y see
the emojis that's graphic God go hit
that up Xbox gamer.com man to get you
laced up right have you looking right
out here in the real put his little site
up there put that joint up there let's
get that link going for graphic guard
cuz he does a lot of what you see on
this show is graphic guard so we got to
pay respect to the legend the OG there
it is y'all go check it out go sign up
show some support no doubt oh you
playing the new fortnite song I mean I'm
saying with the breaking the service all
right all right yeah you doing the no
build mode they got I heard Eminem Drop
it's crazy it's crazy fortnite is just
it's hard to say they not the best live
service I mean it's just they blow up
their world and just do all types of new
stuff it's crazy but anyway got a fun
show for y'all um I think I don't see
the joysticks of the other people in
there cuz uh y going to miss the Mr
lover man himself
he's got uh s's got the anniversary
thing to do it's our anniversary do you
know what to get so sorry joy stick you
Ain
invited no doubt no doubt anytime gra
anytime it's Timmy what's going on so
yeah we going to get addict we going to
get King and uh we have some little
surprise guests pull up you know just to
hang out talk about it Peter Griffin
okay big mad Mo what going on yes yes
yes yes so look we are going to get King
in here he'll be in here soon to kind of
mess up the algorithm with his music and
break all type of stuff when Dr St love
he is not on anniversary with you if he
was you wouldn't be in
here do you know what today is It's s
anniversary it s
anniversary that was the joint y don't
know about that Y Young Bucks don't know
about that that's when a lot of babies
was getting made little R&B
joints and anyway let me St playing with
y'all but again stay T again sh shout
out to the real for um when I shot my
shot for um Lena Hart that that's what's
up yeah we going we going to do that
what you mean stop that noise what you
mean you know about
that anyway catch y'all in a bit get the
rest of the realm up in
here working on sah bar working on it
working on it y'all got to put the
pressure you know when I put the tweets
up shoot the shot y' got to put the
pressure y got to let them know they
supposed to be here y know the in Show
going to be good they know you going to
have a lot of fun y'all got to let them
know y got to be like yo when y'all come
into the real you know what I'm
saying no D he said time C time on C he
said I bet you had the Jerry I ain't
that old D that you talking Jerry cor is
like man that's like coming to America
days with the soul glow and all that nah
s shout out to Aris Mo yeah Eris Mo
killed it we had Aris Mo on the last
word
salute salute what you doing about about
that anyway catch you in a
minute here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all Miss up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
and range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's Swit
that you stop that was dope keep that
keep that going keep that going no go
ahead look I guess you can say that I'm
very spoil to be your dog they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you ain't got to say
it I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell her Uber cuz
it's prettyy hard to sleep on Freddy
kruer
that's let's do that
again here you he you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the range you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest of start regardless back we was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I got's
switch what did you do Don't Stop N that
was dope keep that keep that keep that
going keep that going n Go ahead look I
guess you can say that I'm very spoil
feel to be your dog thing very loyal but
I ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boyal you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flam this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
they can s up in the apartment they call
it department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting and rs you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people on a check
my vocals all on Twitter but I'm antio
love my city but I'm still by I got's
[Music]
Swit get that going n Go ahead look I
guess you could say that I'm very spoil
feel them to be your dogs they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold I ain't
heard the boy you you ain't got to say
it I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougar and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to drama I know it's
random but I addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's sing up in the apartment they
call a department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting and
range you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest of start
regardless back when we was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still coal I
got don't stop that was dope keep that
keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say said it I'm very spoil feel to be
your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be cannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Saron up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the RS you just a Target when
I'm in the range I was the hardest to
start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by I got let's
switch that you don't stop that was dope
keep that going keep that going n Go
ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoil feel to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't heard the boy you ain't got to
say I'm embarrassed for you always been
a nerd never been a loser making Vault
try with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we about to get started I am well
it's not important who I am um what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speak and uh I guess I'm here to keep
you entertained until it's time to get
this show started so
um look y'all to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's standable I kill a beat
and they want to compare me to Freddy
and Jason I rather be Hannibal they be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they it's Saron up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
and range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let Swit
that but what did you doing Don't Stop N
that was dope keep that keep that keep
that going keep that going n Go ahead
look I guess you can say that I'm very
spoiled feel to be your dog thing very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't here the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
kruer
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y' messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being a accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be hanni they
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rign you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
the St regardless back when was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by Coastal I got
let's switch that what did you do don't
stop that was dope keep that keep that
keep that going keep that going go ahead
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoil to be your dog thing very loyal
but I ain't going to hold you I ain't
heard the boy you ain't got to say it
I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess something
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they can Saron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
and range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM got m check my vocals all
on Twitter but I'm antisocial love my
city but I'm still by coal I got Swit
that Stop N that was dope keep that keep
that keep that going keep that going n
Go ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very spoal them to be your dogs they
very loyal but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't he the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
vron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again he you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a accountable and they
say I'm better than money because you
can Bank on me being accountable I know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable I kill a beat and they
want to compare me to Freddy and Jason I
rather be Hannibal they be like why use
a video game just be original y'all to
Dramatical I know it's random but I
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
aring up in the apartment and call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the range you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hard just a started regardless
back we was messaging people on a check
my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
antisocial love my city but I'm still by
coal I
got's what did you do don't stop that
was dope keep that keep that keep that
going keep that going n Go ahead look I
guess you can say that I'm very spoil to
be your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser makeing V try with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's
let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
the song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I
[Music]
got's keep that keep that going keep
that going go ahead look I guess you
could say that I'm very spoil feel to be
your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a
[Music]
nerd
call loud and clear a proclamation of
invitation turn not on
me I cry the prais of
theal the River St lawence with the
[Music]
through I'mma just chilling watch Ste
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young whoop
but then that would mistake me for
addict if I can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cuz if you don't
give with that option you going to be
single player like Sovereign you going
to get tossed in the bushes by King
David royalty and not a pretender
detrimental to a Elemental what a avatar
to a knee Bender I got to be I know it's
my destiny work too who cares if you fly
if you still a mosquito you swear you
ain't something but really be steo you
like to collect stuff and that's cool
but I got bad news even if you really
was that dude can't still be the king of
the statue since a juvenile I've been
cursed with a curse to be Musical and if
you hate it we meet in The Crucible
other than that it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cuz you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's
day oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
start off with that them God Howard bars
we M check right quick K cuz you know we
having technical difficulties today oh M
SI Lord King in the building yeah we
outside you know the feeling 5K you know
we do spin the block on the Ops you know
we real K the L is advancing the line is
advancing ah oh man putting a boot on
they throat not joke
kick the ball over the fence to let him
know who yard is this oh is on it right
there be is on it let's get this thing
going you get slide you get your slide
on what you doing what you going on over
there what you doing over there what's
happening
what I'm going
solo here you here you and we are
live I dropped your mic now going show
oh my ice
cube you ain't going to be playing no
Vaseline
over I shut you down shut you down vers
versus what you call it versus Q yeah oh
man welcome to the IR Lords podcast LLC
and also live on Lords of gaming.net
episode number 333 triple 3 another
glorious Sunday we're back at the round
table on the Lord's day and today we've
got Phil Spencer having no plans for
game pass on PlayStation and
Nintendo you ridiculous you just lost
one yo you stupid not theor hellc
not it's funny how money changing
situation that she was killing it she
was killing it Sega teases something at
the game awards shout out to Xbox you
funny new Fallout in Halo TV trailers oh
Undead Labs
projects and NC soft and Sony
partnership to discuss so we going to
get right into it so let's introduce we
got missing
Lords we back on our kid play K we back
on the Block we back on the Block get
let's go get this shout out to little
addict should be hopefully joining us
shortly he's got a um little power
situation to try to get that rectified
and then can we send love for the it's
our anniversary ah yeah but n you a got
to send CU he having fun though yeah he
having fun he got yeah he having too
much fun right now shout out to s l s
doing what they do I'm sorry Strange
Love but this is what has to happen
right now the man has y the side Boos y
sit back in the bushes shut up it's not
your day you get Valentine's Day the
next day that's on you he said the side
Boos I'm done yeah y on the side SI back
and relax I cannot but anyway let's
introduce the other rest of the realm in
in the round table and of course we have
the Incredible Hulk of this aka the EXs
gamer ooh the prophet of Xbox swamy King
of the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
unequivocal leader of the Xbox front
line movement ooh beloved Lord King how
we doing the drip is very heavy right
now I'm feeling appreciate it that is uh
straight uh you know uh uh uh we mixed
this leather with um piranha and um we
do a piran crocodile and and pan you
know yeah so we got snake and we got you
know I'm feeling like py remember Cobra
Cobra python Patrol yes that's what I
was going for I'm feeling python Patrol
cuz I was looking at tomax and Sab so I
was like I want to try to do a little
toax and saop situation okay okay since
SI l King in the building King all right
I want to give respect to Ryan
Garcia what happened I really want to
give respect to him because he was at
his height then he fought tank and then
he was at his lowest and we also got to
remember uh because Ryan Garcia uh
fought uh dwares last night Oscar dwares
and it's like his team was setting him
up to Fai you know we ain't gonna lie
you know ascar De La Hoya and Bernard
Hopkins having been the you know the
people that was behind this kid when he
lost they left him to the podium by
himself is just training didn't show up
no nobody he was there by himself to
face the world and he said it in the
press conference you know y'all don't
back me but y'all could take that check
though y can sign that check oh he put
the business out yeah yeah he was up
there you know he said you know only
person that got him is Jesus Christ and
his team that he has now his his family
and this is a eye open sobering
situation to a lot of you individuals
people can only be around you as far as
they can use you and this kid knows this
but he didn't let that crumble his world
because he built himself up he
understand he went jogging he went
training he went out he fting heon these
things so the people behind him that's
there are not there that's not helping
you out they don't matter man what
really matters is your connection with
God and your family and he found that
out very early so a lot of these guys
find it out late in life he found it out
very early in life use these people as a
tool the tool that they are useful for
and when he won last night Oscar smiling
Bernard smiling everybody there but when
he lost nobody was there you know and I
felt for the kid and I wanted to know
how he was going to rebound so he went
to dere James that was uh um earol Sim
uh Earl uh
Jor Jun trainer he's with his trainer so
he went there and you know he got his
mind right he says he felt like he a
home in Houston he looked decent he
looked really good he was sharp in his
movements and um he won the fight he won
the fight by knockout in the eighth
round looked really good the dude that
they put him in with was no joke he was
coming for him and it was a really good
fight so I just want to give a shout out
to Ryan Garcia a young man who's uh
understands in life very early the world
is very harsh from man I want you guys
to understand that right now there's
nobody coming to save you there's
nobody's that that's going to come like
no no imaginary savior you got to save
yourself so that boy put in that work
and he didal with exactly what he's
supposed to do and that's what we teach
in the edbox front line this week it's
been fortnite forite yeah it's your week
it's your week it's your week yo shout
out to everybody like me that could not
get into the live event I heard it's
crazy I heard Eminem is De I heard it's
crazy it's it's wild so I was watching
through K not stream right and he got in
there because you know he's a he has a
he has what a million subscribers okay
shout out to the 5K we hit 5K 5K salute
Adidas
0209 hit me um because we have to get
together I don't know if you hit me on
Xbox uh King David OTW hit me there hit
me on my Twitter King David OTW hit me
wherever you can hit me pause and um so
you can get your statue he won the um we
did the raffle thing yeah he won yeah he
won the one0 uh iron Studios black
panther it's dope yeah it's dope so he's
getting that now we have another statue
we giving away this week for the 5K we
got 5K next one is going to be at 10K
and when we hit U 100 um members what
about the Statue for the friends and
family what about what about them
statues oh yeah we got you too
it see like a lot of giving away I'm not
part of this you part of this you part
of this shut
up got he also got to get his stand and
stuff people true true I I gotta get my
my G I got your M yeah yeah yeah yeah so
we gotta get
him anyway this stuff has been shipping
out so um we want y'all people to just
reach out to me get to me and all you
people that did that so we playing um
fortnite so fortnite is yo B I'm not
gonna lie they they they they they had a
100 million people that's crazy 100
million that's crazy and I couldn't get
in that's crazy bro shout out to Bill
still on them team they over there epic
they they doing what they do it's to the
point now it's like them not winning a
live service award is kind of
disrespectful at this point if you
really think and and I'm the fortnite I
came in as the fortnite super hater I I
was pubg then I remember when they did
the Unreal Engine update yeah they did
the 60 frames we was like oh God oh God
they put with the translution and
everything then they took over every pop
culture icon they blow up the world do
all this craziness and then when y'all
had me cuz I was like I never play that
I'm not building no they said oh forget
sir no that was the moment know when
y'all told me about no build mode and I
was like cuz that was to you be in a
gunfight and and do construct a house
and you be like nah fam you know what
I'm saying but when they said n you
ain't got to do that car and I'm like
wait they got a m for that just regular
the guns to guns and we was playing
together I was like yeah they got it
they got it cuz that was my only issue
and then after that surf for Destiny I
was like all right they got me it it is
it is I'm unequivocally Yeah by far the
most topical game moving it's crazy I
want to give a shout out to oh no Alex I
want to give a shout out to fanga and I
want to give a shout out to Mixie yo all
right so those are three uh shows that I
watch you know podcasters that I watch
fanga is never on camera but he has this
little animation yeah that's insane
Mixie is never on camera she has this
little animation Alex is always on
camera he always got his pepperonis he
got the pepperonis out but these
individuals are three individuals that
can say the stuff that I can't say I say
it they way they they they can't say
like they don't they curse yeah I don't
curse right so I watch them to get the
extra laughs
like that's what I would to say the
after do laugh the after I I I love
their content and I love what they bring
you know they push the salt line crazy
they they're they are out here doing the
work of you know there Go adct There He
Go I was trying to hold it up for my man
get oh we got the power let's
go no
[Laughter]
light he he's on
C continue so yeah like the content and
stuff that they do now I don't know if
we could talk about this game that I'm
playing as I'm in beta cuz I'm a beta
boy yeah NDA be careful dudes out here
messing up so I can't say nothing about
that no you can say what what it is you
can say what it is I think okay yeah all
right I think I know what it is yeah
everybody's doing yeah um all right so
I'm playing no you can't no you can't
you can't even say you're playing oh you
can't say you playing thank you ad oh
okay he it's a dope game it's dope it's
do you know I'mma talk around it right
so so so wait hold on so you just talk
baa boy talkad talk to de bable talk do
do what you do do what you
do
got got you debatable right now huh new
Cod easy access Early
Access the easy access this is not easy
access easy access K let's go that's off
that's off boys in the
house so all right I didn't yo all
right it's a DC game yes all rightn wink
wink win a d it's a DC game and um it's
it's a squad based game wink wink wink
wink yes but at the same time though
they put something on the screen that
you can't see your screen yeah yeah cuz
they like don't yeah no no no no it's
your name oh all over oh so if you post
a screenshot they got you they know did
it out of here I I get to say this I
want to say this graphically
the
details sicking just be careful we talk
about next week talk cool sick I back to
you
call fact I want get I think he dve
snitching we don't want that yeah we
don't we don't want the snitching we
don't want that right now else you been
playing what else you yes okay so I go
to my game pass M I think we supposed to
get 30 days of Christmas with these
dudes bro it seems like every day they
dropping a new hit it was the Y who who
was mad at me cuz I kept saying the
Revenant is it it's not the Revenant
King it's the Revenant so so I'm playing
the
Revenant and I'm mad as hell cuz I
purchased Revenant too re The Remnant
too let me say saying let me just stop
doing the adct I I purchased the remnant
too and you know remember I was on I was
like yeah I got to a point where I
needed help yeah I need help that game
is crazy PA pause so um but then I go to
Game Pass is in there I said I could
save myself some money like like I'm mad
as hell so this is where the fearful
stuff comes in from where you don't know
if you should buy something and it it'll
pop up but I like when the Indie Games
is in there because I know Dam well
ain't buying them right so I saw um like
the Lone Wolf joint that they got in
there that intrigues me um because you
know what I'm thinking like you you know
when you play um G of
yes and you see how the fox pop out yes
and you got to follow the fox they got a
whole game right now which just a fox so
my my joint is like this is the spin-off
of the fox I'm done he went
thiso he was so nice he went solo he got
his own Joy so I want to follow the
Nordic Fox so I I downloaded it I'm
getting ready but I'm too busy playing
you know fortnite right now got fortnite
on yeah other than that everything's lit
no doubt no doubt Lord adct I think he's
still a way is he back he's still
working things out behind the scenes yes
he is but uh we got the gaming ninja
himself the Shinobi Lord Cognito spread
that ran not telling what you want to
hear but what you need to hear Shout Out
Mr M play Shout out to finding dude
talking them uh Steam Reviews from
Starfield which is kind of funny and had
a funny debate about AI King you would
have loved it you would have loved it
well so what side does he oh he on your
side oh he's on your side he's on your
side he's like nah we got to talk about
it so I had made up the F you know me
with the instigating so I would had the
funny um scenario for him right cuz I
was like all right cool I get it you
ethics and you worried about certain
things fair right so I said see me and
you know this reference you going to get
it so I was like there was a character
in G Joe named sentor and I said he was
made up of all the DN of the greatest
leaders and they put it together I
said this Command right so I said I said
so what if all the great Ty Howard Drew
carpatian all the great rid pass away
and they submit their joint to this and
you can you had the AL the AI algorithm
that you can make the story just written
the story or whatever it is from them
with the greatest the greatest artist
and the greatest so he's like he's like
I'm just saying like they shouldn't even
contribute to the I said but somebody
that's right I'm with him because I
think okay so that I wouldn't want it
you want you want so okay so Tupac they
be like say he's alive and they like all
right cool you spit some balls into the
algorithm he he submit to joint and then
then you get the the Tupac GPT well they
got that now I know so and I'm not a fan
of it cuz right now I go on YouTube and
I don't know I sent something to you
yeah does I send something to to you the
other day was Slick Rick and was Big
Daddy
Kan I didn't know if it was real if it
was fake yeah yeah and I'm and I'm
sitting here at we're at a point right
now where we're being fo like they got a
lot of Joe Rogan
um AI like chat joints like okay so if
you scroll on Tik Tok there's a lot of
people using Joe Rogan's voice to talk
about fake stuff and it'll be and you
know You' be like N I ain't your WR but
it because it'll get to a point where it
gets too ridiculous but there are there
are instances where it's
indistinguishable between the person and
the AI I think that is a terrible thing
I feel you you on the side of question
so yeah you're about the ethics and
regulation right so like well for for
our
industry I'm trying to preserve the
human nature of it all you trying to get
the spirit the soul that's where you at
all right cuz you know um the the AI
can't create right it's whatever you
yeah whatever you
feel but we're going to get to the point
where that AI is going to become
sentient and and who's to say yeah but
who's to say that it hasn't become
sentient right I'm in there I made it
happen
right see see
yeah I'm here I'm here for this I'm here
for this
wait his phone is the first phone that
has it and they hid in his phone I can't
wait man I'm going have Skynet down I'm
be down so I'm be down before I they
need a emary to be able to talk to y'all
when they take over so I'm going be
complient my heart this is my my heart
car
get get yo my heart my cuz you know you
get your greatest HK scory stories ever
the greatest what if they fix the MCU
they be all fire now they they stick to
the source
material no like no so what happened to
Tyson wititi what happened to like when
is enough enough we need sentor we need
this no no that's okay so you're
confusing uh you're you're mixing
cloning no I'm taking the greatest
leaders of all time in Edie JRA they get
to feed the algorithm and create what
King always wanted and live forever you
don't want to listen to Michael Jackson
dude but they do that now and it's not
nice like it's not nice we going to do
this for SE show we going to do it for
we going to do it we going to do it for
show hold this we going to say this but
this this for a patreon we going to do
this for a patreon going be
aat
yeah I'm opposed to
this so what I was going to say so we
got that and then um shout out to the
last word man shout out to you B shout
shout out we had the legendary Mora
gandora man oh man Eris for those who
don't know she plays Eris mour in
Destiny that's the voice actress and um
she was awesome she's also done Moss VR
she's done the um that her her catalog
is crazy that was awesome so for me um
yeah I've been doing Destiny um season
of the wish you know what I mean that's
just lit a lot of stuff going on I know
I know it's not it's not popular to talk
about that season of the wish we wish
y'all wasn't purchased by
Sony it's actually cor la la la that's
right so shady there we
go there we go so um we got that and
don't feed into his no feed in I'm down
I'm Cobra I'm
Cobra I'm all that python patrol all
that and played cocon cocon shout out to
um those guys over there yeah it's cool
cuz those are the people remember the
people that made inside they had split
up so one half of that guest team went
and they did some of it which I still
like so I call that Dad that's the D
side they got the graph they got the you
know what I'm saying but the mom side I
was worried cuz I was like I don't know
if y'all got the the artistic Vision I
like but I'm not going to front oh my
God that game is amazing that game is
puzzles do the puzzles crazy jumping in
the three dimension going between worlds
and it's insane cocon is fire salute to
that so let me ask you a question yes
sir did they did the split who you think
did the split best it's funny cuz Badd
asked me yeah I think listen dad was
looking good at first but his the thing
the problem with sumerville is amazing
if you end the game has one of the best
moral choices I've ever seen with
multiple endings it's great it's a
heartfelt story but there's technical
issues that prevented from being great
he's almost perfect he needed that Mom's
touch that fine comb to really you know
what I'm saying and Mom's thing is at
first I was like oh you need that you I
don't know there's one button and it
looks simple simple and I was like then
she's like hold up and the game just
flips on it head they just slowly
building you up to mechanics it's like
four or five mechanics on mechanics and
going between worlds and and then you
got this thing with this almost is
perfect oh man so I have to front I
can't front cocoon is the is the heart
that's the soul that's the yeah so I I
have to say right as of now the that
developing team that made Kon I think
they're a little ahead you know what I'm
saying as far as where where the I the
same thing yeah I hope they get back
together cuz I think think when they was
together they made inside I know it's
over it's probably they both got their
separate companies but that's why man
some people say cocon yeah fire 10 out
of 10 yeah it's awesome it's awesome I I
have to I can't front on that so we got
that ad is the back is he not back yet
not he's back he's but remember the dude
is there yeah so he doing the thing all
right cool so what I'll do I'm sorry
there's no solve but I'm going to have
to uh try my
best let me pull up the uh the J and
then um yeah actually let me bring
somebody in too we got some stuff we got
to bring oh shout out to Gerald MCM for
37 months all hail the ILP #r beards
have a real love gaming you new dude
should try it # love the hobby salute
The Gamers salute Pony up $5 Super Chat
hope Xbox terms are more a minimal than
Sony given their focus on building out a
legacy marketplace with OG 360 it would
seem self-defeating
otherwise okay all right Robert kellet
Lords and gaming.net in the building $2
Super Chat bless day Lords excited for
the ad Awards wow the ad Awards you
messy uhoh shout out to hood ninji
gaming and
entertainment $50 Super Chat Todd Howard
is the greatest troll in gaming he lied
and said star Starfield has a new game
plus he then rolls credits at the end of
every chapter if One reviewer would have
selected replay they would have The
Narrative continues thus # Starfield has
no new game plus he say he a got no new
game plus y he say Tod is out here lying
he feels very strongly about this I I
don't know where this is coming from but
okay well I think that was sarcasm for
the $50 okay no no I se I've seen this
guy before I mean well I I appreciate
your $50 for you to say that but um
there is new game
PL I mean if you choose not to continue
I mean maybe he like the structural
definition maybe because you don't end
it and then there's a screen that say
start Press Start and then says New Game
Plus as opposed to says replay your game
start oh I don't want to spoil it cuz
you didn't I know how to do well I was
playing Starfield this week yeah I you
play it but I know you a finish n my
thing is I'mma do what I wantan
to this is the beauty of this game I'mma
do what I want to but also if you are
upset that you start all over and it's
more the world is flushed out you know
where it is and you got everything that
you had before but that's not New Game
Plus to you I don't know what to tell
you but that sound like New Game Plus to
me like cuz I finished Spider-Man and
just because it just start right back
off there they just drop you in the
world and say go for it and you got all
your stuff that sounds like new game
plus you but see this the thing with Tod
join is there's other
content I'm just swinging around the
same stuff the book bag ain't there no
more it's just the same stuff maybe
means the implementation I guess I guess
maybe that's foral I don't know I don't
know explain explain CU we want to
respect Pony up $2 super chat again King
David taking it to these
Philistines oh my God y please don't
associate me with that oh I just
realized that was bad yeah dror Strange
Love $2 we gonna move on $2 I forgot
that was bad please don't let adct read
the super chats y'all don't do don't do
them like that Dr oh man he's dope like
that no doubt let's play with each
other's Joy sck $5 Super Chat I don't
want to know if s playing me don't let
it show cuz my heart can't take it
anymore anymore if you play me please
don't boo boo you been you been to s p
yo what was that joint that's a ill song
what Was That Joint that was a Mario W's
joint yeah that's the joint from puffy
yeah oh damn this is not the time this
is not the time everybody's out of
political pocket
trying to cast yeah we can't we ain't
hanging out with brother
love we can't associate with brother
love anyway um Nintendo theu $2
superchat fortnite game of the
generation it's
undeniable King do you agree it's it's
different it's not even you at this
point in time is is part of our fabric
of society it's not it's not is it is
you know what it is when this like let's
say the world was to end tomorrow MH and
another alien form comes down here and
say what was they doing fortnite will be
our game like that that they would use
that game as the peak because it is in
more Minds than anybody that I've ever
seen I can see why people chasing that
bag let's be real king uh epic would to
have those aliens in the game by the
next Wednesday okay you know about those
aliens
right oh he don't know about the alien
oh sorry my bad you good you good I
don't know what's going on I don't know
what's happening anyway uh dror Strange
Love $2 Super Chat I'm no side meal King
I'm the main cause for Sol mental
illness is something that we all should
check and um all I will tell you is yeah
whatever he told you no you did not do
that you are ridic
what whatever he told you
booo wink wink yeah you you the main
ca he said whatever he told you I am
done with you you think he the main
cause Coco he
not you are ridiculous I cannot hold on
one second we got a little there we go
let's take this J off the screen there
we go all right cool we got uh some
guest pulling up and we going you know
it's time to talk talk about things a
little bit time to talk about things
what going on with Lord gaming.net y'all
you know what I'm saying yes sir shout
out to the team shout out mmon in the
Bell let me get a mic check right quick
mmon just want make sure I hear you good
check one two check yeah turn yourself
up a little bit turn yourself up a
little bit little little little louder
if you can there we go but while you
doing that uh yeah man it's that time to
celebrate Lords of gaming.net man you
know very proud you we got a lot of
writing Talent this month and you know
the past month and and just to see the
influx of great articles and and people
coming on to the team very exciting time
right now I I call it the new draft
class you know what I'm saying the new
draft class them pulled up they're doing
it they they Absolut um killing it and
we're absolutely blessed to have the
Riders we have but uh now it's time to
celebrate one that went Above and Beyond
in the month of November he was
absolutely on a tear as a rookie pretty
much you know amazing editorials on both
Xbox Sony future Bethesda I mean you
name it the kids been on it and he
dropping some news pieces so we probably
present the latest winner of the Lord
dizzy loget scribe of the month to my
man Lord Joseph lefl I like that name
LEF remember um
[Laughter]
LEF salute to the legend the rookie he
could not make it but he has some BS for
us so we're going to let him get his
bars
off hello Lords and Ladies of the realm
I think s said he is going to be gone
this week but hello addict King
Cognito thank you for uh letting me have
a minute thank you very much to the
editors of Lords of gaming.net for
choosing me a scriber of the month I'm
shocked honored humbled and grateful for
that title thanks um shout out special
shout out to the other authors at Lords
of gaming.net incredible work new
article just went up by Lord Eugene
excellent excellent piece on game
preservation check it out and uh shout
out to my wife and
kids to my family still in New York and
to all those who have moved
away grateful for all of you
thanks we are back salute to left FL
Lea me style you probably might not like
that
respect on his name p respect this is
our scribing a month he's absolutely
killing it and again proud to have you
on the team brother make sure you hit s
up and uh we'll take care of you on that
and then uh yeah there's a secondary
award that we do and uh this one is
again what I consider you know what a
part of diy's vision which is kind of
nurturing Talent you know being that
calm soothing voice of reason you know
the person that everyone goes to and who
leads by example not only you know with
his influence you know he's a he's a
great writer himself you know all found
time with all the stuff he does on the
back end as far as the editing and
everything else but finds time to drop a
nuanced opinion piece you know I'm
talking about the game awards and
nominations and uh had a torac 3
remaster review very Stellar so we
probably present the winner of the Lord
Disney lognet editor of the month to my
man editor and chief Lord Weck AKA Lord
mchm in the building how we doing sir
speech speech
appreciate it so much guys you guys have
been uh you know it's been it's been
exactly four years since I join loget so
time does fly so it's been a fantastic
uh ride uh I just want to say anyone who
is watching this Live Now by all means
appli to join log Nets we're always
looking for new writers you know we're
trying to uh what do they call it a call
to arms or what was that you guys call
of arms you know so I'm I'm I'm
officially announcing it if you want to
join loget just shoot us an application
we'll get you settled and uh best of
luck to all of you and it's just been
big part of my life uh right now and uh
yeah I enjoy all the time they spend
with the writers and yeah I just want I
love seeing it grow and let's hope we
have a great 2024 as well nice look
brother you know words cannot describe
how much I appreciate you on the team
like you don't even know like where we
would be without you I'm putting the
sight in there and just like mmud said
um again if you guys are interested you
know you're looking to get in the break
in and you know hit the site go to the
contact us section there's a radio
button you can hit that we've got a lot
of people I see joining up from the
realm and again you know just make sure
you send the writing a sample piece of
something you're passionate about so we
can take a look at it and then we'll
we'll get back to you but I'm very proud
of you brother and uh always look
forward to our our chats and and
foolishness during the middle of the day
while we actually uh preparing and
thinking about stuff but excited for
next year we got big plans for next year
and again could not have done this
without you but you keep the vision
Spirit of long n alive and I'm very
appreciative and I need to tell you that
every time I talk to
you appreciate it appreciate the kind of
words Cog and you know I just want to
wish you guys a great show and I'll be
catching you I'll be in the chat so uh
join us and have some fun guys no doubt
no doubt blesss I thought I thought when
I saw mm pop in I was like okay so we
got you know our for I mean mm can hang
out if he want I don't want put pressure
to man got a family but I I always give
the option like you know if I thought I
thought I thought he was stepping in for
I thought he was going to get you know
some sol got
little part time that's that's what I
thought I can roll my RS as well just as
good as hey hey joystick you heard
that oh man you get joystick on your
timeline be
careful no doubt shout out to puckish
Rogue 100 follow Super Chat who's the
best robot fighter uh Killer Instinct
full Gore Mortal Kombat sector or Tekken
Jack 8 or do you have a better robot
fighter cyber Akuma does it count
thoughts well I would go with f go but
um best robot fighter technically would
have to be
Ultron okay I mean technically but if
you're going to talk about one that we
can play in um in in a a fighting game
I'm going to have to go with fuga he
he's the best to me no doubt no doubt uh
M Moon any thoughts on that were you
good he's not a robot technically but's
the the wood guy in Tekken M Jin M Jin
yeah yeah yeah he's but he's pretty he's
pretty cool though yeah like training
dummy yeah I remember that he had a
silver version of him like a robot I
forgot tattoo Jin or something like that
no doubt let's get to it what else we
got we got that we got the super chats
okay so we um also have the patreon
question so what we're going to do shout
out to snail killer oh boy let me get
ready for
this hello pause
Lords since last week Senpai asked us
who gets Cog and since Lord shinovi did
not want to acknowledge the nonc
colorful chat I will now act as the
voice of the
voiceless chat since it was the birthday
of the Shinobi what kind of party did he
have I'll have a few suggestions to what
happened a hot dog party UK Style
sausages
in sausages in buns with mayo
everywhere
yo option
two barbecue
bom bring your own meat where K will act
as GM Grill Master and will handle
everyone's
meat yo c r arcade Iron Fist
tour an arcade fighting tournament where
the Shinobi faces off a series of
opponents by manipulating the double
joysticks I leave the chat to decide
what exactly happened thank you Lords
for the awesome year of content one more
week before vacation
time snail killer happy birthday to
thank you for your
patronage uh uh yeah King what what
party did I have according I he he said
that to the chat no he said oh yeah he
said it to the chat he said to CH to
theat put me on the spotlight I I I
don't know what's going now leave the
chat to decide uh yeah one dror Strange
Love immediately responded one hot dogs
um let's see what we got straing order
party that's what yeah I I definitely
felt violated I felt violated I felt
uncomfort I felt groomed I was was being
groomed can't use that I can't use that
word s Cassie you know yeah yeah Joy STI
you got this okay all right so I only
see one vote two V oh dip down says one
all right so y'all want the hot dog
party UK style all week Mexican all all
weak sausage party why I got to be all
week yo y'all doing the most y'all doing
the most so you have a freak off y k
don't do that K don't do that too soon I
know what you doing
k
yo so we going to move on we going to
move on we already got enough votes and
that's enough so um user not found says
hope everyone has had a great week and
is having a great Sunday so far just
wanted to ask two small questions first
do the Lords think that there will be
another Starfield like direct next year
30 to 40 minute showcase for just one
game but it can or says it can be but
doesn't necessarily need to be attached
to the June showcase and if they do
another which game out of the first
party Xbox game studios you know ABK but
that the Xbox game Studio publishing
regardless of it's if it's announced for
next year would you like to see this
direct be on again hope everyone enjoys
the upcoming holidays and remember to
stay safe so that's what we got there so
uh yeah what what what you got as far as
um a small a direct um what do you think
you know it should be on if they do like
another Starfield like direct what do
you think okay about like a dive yeah
yeah yeah continue um they're going to
be doing a deep di they're going to be
doing a deep dive on a valve uh I think
you're G to get that and you're G to get
another Deep dive oh we have the time
and Whatchamacallit going on sorry sorry
we're gonna be doing another dip uh deep
dip down we gonna be doing another uh
Deep dive into um Sena Saga too I I
believe that uh that game you're going
to be surprised with from the stuff that
I heard with the combat I think you're
going to be surprised with it so they're
going to have to talk about that you
know and get everybody all lathered up
and ready for the when the game drops
why
got hey they was talking about brother
love and all this other stuff they gave
you a whole sausage party for a week oh
man that's crazy that's crazy yeah Mayo
all over the place he wild crazy they
wild crazy B your thought sir do you
think there will be another Starfield
like direct for a single game and if so
which one do you think it would be on oh
yeah for sure I think just echoing of
what king said a and Sena Saga is
definitely the light most likel games
that will get it but I'm pretty sure one
of them is going to be right after E3 as
well so there will probably be one maybe
earlier the year and one about E3 just
similar to what happened this year with
II Russian Starfield I like that I like
that all right all right I'mma go with
I'll go with um
one I don't know if they do I guess
first of all I'll say hellblade
hellblade it has to be has to show the
combat cuz you know that's all we care
about at this point let's see the
fighting let's see let's get it on um I
don't know the timeing it maybe first
half of the year or maybe maybe it is
like what mmon says where they um
combine it as part of like how they did
with Starfield where it's the Showcase
and then it's okay hellblade you know
gameplay reveal or there's a part of me
that says you give hellblade its own
direct and because ABK is this year you
need a lot more time to focus on all the
studios of ABK at E3 so to speak right
so maybe it's the you know how it was
like the Microsoft and Bethesda showcase
to let people yo this is what's going on
this is what's happening we're together
I think there needs to be like a
Microsoft and Activision showcase kind
of verbiage to let people know remember
the Casual some of them don't know like
yo this is the new home of Call of Duty
and Y Yad y so to speak so they're G to
know next year oh
man you know next year when you going to
turn on your PlayStation and the says no
PlayStation 6 you're
ridiculous
anyway moving on another uh final
patreon question shout out to the homie
dip down games in anime he's back y'all
here we go what we got to save what we
got to do cuz you know it's going to be
crazy pause I was playing with him
yesterday in fortnite yo sh shout out to
him jumping in the party his character
not there but then when we start the
game he show up mysteriously kind of
weird stuff but shout out to dip down
that's the homie he said well it's
happening again the world is under
attack it's crazy this time by the
galactic gargoyle cousin of the
dimensional Dragon you four have to
agree you can only play one multiplayer
game for the rest of your lives okay
Destiny 2 fortnite Street Fighter 6 on
Nintendo Smash Brothers PS Cog please
put the beef to the side this time pause
you did kind of single-handedly destroy
the world last time oh yeah yeah cuz y
was talking that stre nonsense yeah yeah
yeah beef was not trying to hear none of
that um so yeah so this I think we could
all agree on this one I think we could
if there's one multiplayer game that we
all play I'm going to put the vote out I
think we would all be comfortable with
Halo as the single one do you hell no no
hell no you traitor hell no you traitor
you ain't Advan take his Advance line we
just we just we just had the
conversation if the world ended tomorrow
and the aliens came down and see what we
play fortnite for the rest of our life
but yes cuz that's the only one that's
going to change oh yes Halo will be the
same one no man no no y I see y'all
doing nice stuff over there that's
cute but yo 100 million people will
refer to fortnite like Eminem is a
fortnite is Eminem taking this mask off
in Halo I just want to know I mean juice
world we had little Wayne come on LeBron
James and them LeBron James like no no
taco Tuesdays bad this what is what is
happening what is happening hereo are
you the same man that we are you the
same man we we we we bought four
physical TVs and did a network party are
you the man that bought the Xbox console
before are you the man that is the Xbox
um hold the line Ambassador are you the
yes yes yes I'm also the guy that put in
40 hours a week at
fortnite I'm also that
dude turn what the turn the world knows
the
truth yo we can say I don't care how it
smell we ain't dying this time yo we
gonna keep it 100% real I love the hell
out of Halo I'm not playing Halo for the
rest of my
life all right so adct what you voting I
gotta go fortnite too
oh my the thing is build mode or no
build mode that's the main question no
if it's build mode then I'm
going good you got to play the way the
developers tell you no build mode you're
coming with me you're coming with me so
Halo guns or no guns what the hell is
that y your game got that your game got
houses your game got construction but it
has the it has the ability to say yes or
no like yo we got to take that game in
it
totality that game in its totality is no
game like it let's stop playing games
here wow let's stop doing
this the voice of reason and loget what
your thoughts
here all the way you know I can't play
that Home Depot game any you know that's
this guy he said on Depot he said you
got you got your edit of the month
goodbye
now he got to leave he got got go he got
to go like he got to go I thought he was
down I thought he was down for the crown
he got wow I'm I'm I'mma tell Xbox about
this let them know let I'm tell Xbox
about this J they got a 100 million
people playing that game sitting in the
queue for two hours y I saw a dude that
said I I got two hours on my
queue yo it smiled it
smiled I I don't want to hear it people
sat there and waited 2 hours to play a
again ain't nobody sitting and Wai for 2
hours for Halo thing though I'm if I'm
at the stick you know my flag and games
the service then the thing I'm I'm doing
it on fortnite because to me I trust
epic to support fortnite as a games of
service a lot more than I trust 343
there we go Bill still come get get your
people come get your people man you have
infiltrated this podcast you've
infiltrated this podcast epic epic games
Tim swe Jesus no we were playing that
before that happened like not okay yeah
King have we not been playing fortnite
for like two years at this point yep
I've been indoctrinated you the Halo you
and your are you the guy that that that
that is is the guy that plays the forge
modes and with your brother and
firefight and are you the guy is it that
you so the guy that can make that CH
because I play them okay interesting wow
this is great yes he's the he's the full
Halo package pul he got a whole dude
that comes at them called Halo Reach
Around king would king would you not
agree that someone that plays the game
pretty consistently can can deter or not
I'm not no I'm not talking about you I'm
talking about I play the game
consistently I've seen the the turmoil
I've seen the issues now I'm not saying
that heyo turn your they said turn your
back up you say little low yeah yeah a
little low a little low little low I'm
not saying that Halo doesn't have the
opportunity to like really Captivate
something and I'm not saying that they
won't uh but one thing I will say is
they are so they're they're they got a
long way to go before they touch
something like fortnite y somebody
stupid he said Co massachus fortnite you
got your ha that's it put him right in
there wow that's crazy all right concern
with fortnite it's it's they're always
pivoting the game started out as like a
like a tower defense game then they did
the Battle Royale game and then they
removed the the building from the Battle
Royale game now they're doing like a
Roblox kind of thing so that always
pivot that's it's going to create a a
really negative a game that's what makes
a good games as a service the ability to
Pivot in a correct Manner and do it fast
and Swift that's what makes a good game
tell the TR Shane the devil let it be
true so instead of for the next thousand
years you playing the same map
like see just just looking at fortnite
and epic are Kings at oh you doing that
in Battle Royale and it actually makes
sense let me let me get
that that's dope I like that bar let me
use that before before Apex Legends we
uh King you didn't have revive buses on
on fortnite and they're like oh you guys
find a unique way in Battle Royale to
bring people back let me hold
that let borrow that mic on your arm
buch of fr
soon as he got his character anime
characters he betrayed us that's right
that's what
I with though like they cost them a lot
a lot of the layouts were attributed to
directly to like the Creator program
that they do so it's a double-edged
sword you know like okay they can pivot
they can get more people in but
sometimes is at the cost of some of the
employees there so it's it's kind of
ugly you know but it's the end of the
world we just we're just going to die
gone the employees are gone we just got
games let's go get
it anyway Lord addict where can to find
people what's going on with you brother
everything good you know my brother from
another mother the difficult game
conqueror Lord of his own world uh so
far I hope everyone likes the new oh is
fire I'm about
to well not I wasn't talking about the
peacock Everyone likes the new
setup I have the ability to to raise my
desk now show show add show them show
them yeah look at that look at that
that's the only he's shrinking he's
shrinking he's shrinking Shing shrinking
oh yeah he got small he got small there
you
go he's ridiculous that's it's fine I'm
feeling it I'm feeling it man yeah so
this is this is the new way I'm be
looking in these streets yeah okay uh
yeah first off you know want to shout
out to everyone that uh that followed
the the attic
Arena H having a I ain't even made a
stream over there and already have
people going over there nice uh right my
my my goal is to to set everything up in
the first of next year you know when I
play fortnite with with King and them
you I plan on going back I plan on going
back and playing Final Fantasy 7 remake
up to
rebirth so you know I appreciate coming
through definitely you know go and uh
follow it if you guys uh want to to see
that content and you know for my messy
streams you know I I plan on doing some
more of that stuff and you know
apparently like look can I guarantee you
that what I was streaming on my channel
for a couple weeks that's what resulted
in the viewership dip a little bit no
but my mindset was I'm going just make
another Channel not even risk it not
even attempt to to to find out what it
is so over there you I'm going to be uh
doing a lot more uh live streams uh
hopefully I'm going to be collaborating
with content creators you know uh Chase
3mg uh you know I think I'm going to
play um K
not yeah man it would be crazy if I
could collab with Ka that I don't know I
think I think I can make it happen I
don't think my blood pressure can handle
it I'm be real with you don't worry
don't worry don't worry don't worry
we'll give you some nox outside you'll
be good but um you know it's it's been
good I I I do think I want to play
redmet with King though because it's on
Game Pass and yeah and I paid for it so
we can do see I didn't I got that game
pass I'm so salty with that that game
pass P you waited you held
out no doubt such a good game as well
you know the fomo got the hell out of me
uh mmud like the yo s was like really I
was like
yeah I can just see it now key he's
right there where is he I heard the
bosses in that game's hard they're
they're not easy what like what like the
game is ridiculous and I heard people
talking about they wanted um what is it
oh look Troy addict said addic held the
light and King didn't yeah for real yeah
yeah I'm sorry I fell into I'm listen
I'm human don't with look King King held
the line I Advanced the line yeah for
real anyway that's been this sir no
doubt all right so oh hold on Donald you
cannot be sending joints while we live
all right I'm going read cuz you you my
man but yeah from now on if you're a cut
off time bro yeah if your stuff isn't
there yeah my
Showtime no by 800 a.m. the day of yes
then it's just going to it's a it's a
it's a squash exactly it's a one time
situation cuz I like Donna talk about
other than that it ain't happening no
more all right create the perfect
quadruple a studio led by four directors
of your choice with one that have 10,000
devs at their disposal so the studio
head the gameplay director The Narrative
director and the art graphical director
who can create the best possible
Studio what you think man um okay so my
choice would be Cliffy
b top top as far as as far as uh the
direction goes then
um U what's this guy this crazy dude
God of War oh you want you want bog in
there too yeah no no no oh damn
disrespect oh the original how you going
disrespect the new one and you like this
is not me that's trash like I'm not even
going to act like that thing exists I
really wanted to go away I really wanted
to go away it's like watching a season
of Loki like watching paint dry best
salute to Cory bog yeah yeah
yeah dis
yeah if I'm going to the Sony stable I'm
stealing nail dman nobody's looking for
him nobody
checking I'm checking for nail um and
then then add nil uh dman to it for uh
story uh uh narrative and then the
artwork artwork I would have to take Rod
Ferguson because I know he gonna get it
over the line and I think him and
cliffyb can work together he can have
everybody in one team so that be my
dream team okay all right all right what
about mm any uh your great Studio you
know what would be your your your
perfect triple uh quadruple a studio led
by four directors of your choice yo I
thought we had the
Stanfield how you do my man like that
how you do yo
everything everything I said did it did
it yo everything I love you guys are
ridiculous I thought that was LE St I yo
I got hands on my arm just
[Music]
up is super lit today I blame you just
go ahead and leave I'll take it take I
was working the
FES I am not GNA lie
yo like you like my movies
King oh God y I just finished watching
Atlanta so you cuz I'm checking the
messages I pick my I said
oh I said call call through the the
crazy hell Mary this is it s here we got
to go get a
superstar we made it we made it m we
made it to days I said nobody text me
this is the greatest
day y I ain't going front three bit
what's
up you call me
for real you you turn this podcast into
something different just y'all killing
me y'all killing me Lord three what's
going on how we doing sir I'm doing
pretty good man I just I just uh came
home so it was like perfect timing jump
in with the fan of course of course give
me give me a little microphone level
just a little bit High we want to hear
you even L louder than put a little bit
higher there there it is there it is I
forgot to show you I forgot to show you
guys I almost I almost uh ended my
brother's life over this we have like a
bunch of lanterns from out the years and
I turned around look what he put as a
lantern it's a final fantasy 16
Lantern oh the 16 joint okay okay salute
salute I was like I know you did not
just put that that travesty on my
keys No Doubt so uh mm you were in the
middle of answering before King lost his
mind I'm sorry my bad let's go let's go
what you got so your studio head this is
is four directors of your choice Studio
head gameplay director narrative
director art graphical
director uh I would have a comea to
block everyone on Twitter oh yo and then
I'll
have you mess and I'll have um just the
team behind the mass effect to I don't
know who's responsible for that but they
terms like gameplay mechanics narrative
wise
uh who who who the guys who did like
Resident Evil 4 I forgot his name Oh you
mean
wa you didn't was it Mami I forgot them
I think it was Mami yeah okay Mami and
for graphics graphic yeah I don't know a
lot of the graphical directors I got to
do my research on that yeah man just uh
just something that looks like we could
have done research at donu if Don would
gave us time and stop sending us patreon
questions live during the
show these are examples questions let's
be honest yeah yeah all right no doubt
we you got a strong team as it is you
could you good right there you think
about something you're add it as we go
on yeah yeah for sure no doubt let's get
uh addict man your four directors of
your choice to make your perfect
quadruple a
studio Rob Ferguson is definitely going
oh you stole mine yep I was going with
Ferg big fer I need that
management we need the game to come out
on time facts I thought about that
whoever just designed the gameplay of
Last of Us Part Two uh I'm going need to
snatch him too truck drop that's why I
took nail yeah okay
I I mean Neil is like overall I don't
I'm talking about the person for the
combat
itself um the
art what you doing that's hard right
can't figure it out I say the person who
who's in charge of the art for God of
War
Ragnarok cuz that game did look nice
okay and what was the last one um art
graphical director narrative director
gameplay director narrative
narrative uh I'll probably
take n not coima you
a I want to be able to comprehend my
story oh yo
L need some be able to comprehend I
would say the the people who did make
Mass Effect uh franchise okay so we
doing um what's my man the The Originals
like Casey Hudson and them that's if I
was
allowed guaranteed three games
if not it was like a one and done then
you know that said he only nice if he
could spit
16 the thing is if I'm not going to
reach out to a developer that excels at
storytelling over a few games if I don't
have a few games so if it's like a
oneand done type of scenario then I
would
probably I would reach out
to probably the uh the uh the the father
of Final Fantasy the person over Miss
Walker because I feel like he he writes
really good
stories I like I like that he he wrote
lost artist let me let me get some
developer Insight here let's get let's
get a little bit you know what I'm
saying so this is your perfect quadruple
a studio studio head change my mind
three back and just control
everything we can for the AR you know we
got him you know what I'm saying I'm
just jumping in but
so no we got to play with your chess
yeah we need fours yeah four four
directors of of your choice Studio head
gameplay director narrative director art
graphical director this is your perfect
quadruple a
studio for uh graphical let's see I
really like the art director who who uh
did uh high-fi rush I think he he's up
coming he uh had um Knowledge from the
guy who did the the other franchise a
horror franchise I can't remember the
name um was it Evil Within Evil Within
Evil Within yes yes yeah when we
interviewed him he was like he had a uh
the uh Jo John I think is his name yeah
John johanes John Johannes he's the
person over over that whole team he was
just pretty much like it's weird being
like that fresh into the scene and he
was over people that was like vets for
like 10 15
years yeah I I feel he could bring a
fresh perspective with my game you know
be kind of cool I like that I like that
um so we so let's do that for graphical
and for story I kind of want to go with
I think his name is tamim and tanates
who did hellblade o oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I know who you're talking
about I know exactly who you're talking
about that's what's up so I making an
Xbox game at this point right yeah
might this is a XBox exclusive exclusive
exclusive for my game MH um let's see
for for that would be art Direction so
if I'm going Graphics I'll put the
Coalition there
facts yeah u e five heavy heavy yeah
okay um I think I got one more what am I
missing um you are you got I think it's
four right you got the uh Studio head
you got the um gameplay D put I didn't
put Studio head I'll put Sarah Bon up in
there oh we doing she' be my studio head
okay okay all right that's a good look
that's a good look I'm cheating cuz the
people I have kind of all do the same
thing so I'm cheating um Studio had
probably like adct said I'm going with
big Ferg going ra Ferguson we got to
ship it we got to get it on time it's
going to be high quality gameplay
director I cannot go against my man's
the zamp vit zampella he going to direct
the show he going to hold it down
narrative I'm going to go with um Amy
headache I want some I I want her to get
in her bag I want her to get like I want
her to get make me like a legacy of fa
victus the original PlayStation joint
you know I'm saying with the narrative
the vampire walking through all that
good stuff she making a I think with the
Black Panther she doing something right
now but um yeah uh Captain America is it
yes it's like Captain America black
panther so salute to her art graphic I'm
sorry I don't know anybody enough so I
need to do my research this is spring on
me last um last minute but I'm just
going to grab up Casey Hudson from the
Mass Effect team and say pick the
graphical people you had
and I'm that's what I'm Casey bring the
mullet I love the mullet and bring all
your people from Canada and let's do
this bring the mullet party in the back
y'all you know the party in the back
back in the day V in the front party the
back what that's my man right I know for
some reason I feel like that those heads
would Clash and people would end up
believe Ferguson to get him in line
though Ferguson to get line mullet for a
second I think the mullets were C listen
they going have to listen to zap zap got
the track GRE he like look man I don't
made the Call of Duties I don't made the
Titan Falls I don't got Jedi Survivor
what I can't do you can't talk to me he
just he just need fusing the dire Co
just tried to pull the initiative in the
exact scenario gonna happen look I would
I would have grabbed um David Giga you
know what I'm saying cuz he he you don't
he don't you don't get in line a whole
bunch of Crystal D shirts to come into
the studio and get you out
of the game in a
decade that's why we got big fur that's
we got big fer the games will get out
the door fer there that's the reason why
I put Ferg there gam going to get out
gamees going to get out the door salute
to the Donald that was actually a really
really good one all right PO on to end
and the people were spoken the rumors of
Xbox having a presence at the game
awards which of these would have the
biggest impact on the show winner of the
four-way IP poll at 33% of the
vote gear six gear six what it people
want that gear six right there coming in
at second place 24% of the vote was I
don't care Jeff got to admit that Xbox
tax is
real that's what they want at the game W
okay cool and third place at 23% of the
vote Indiana Jones and in last place at
only 18% of the vote surprisingly hell
blade too they don't want to see it no
more at the game they don't l king your
thoughts well I mean gears it's time
it's time for us to have gears we
already have Foo we already have Halo
Halo is knocking Destiny smooth out in
the streets Destiny laid down the
streets Halo standing all over it I I've
never thought I'd see 343 put the boot
on their chest but you know Kong will
dieza for out here spinning the block on
Gran Turismo so it's only fair you know
Gears of War 6 come out to just put the
final na in the coffin on God of War
it's just only fair that you know we
kill Kong appropriately that's everybody
get together and kill Kong let's go
shout out to F gaming in the building he
said Kong like the pics um kiss move he
said Amy hasn't Shi a game in a decade
that's why we got fur kiss Moon that's
why I got fur see she going to get it
she going to make it happen thought
about it exactly exactly so we got that
and then um before we move on just want
to make sure yeah super chats coming in
I miss you s I miss you um we got let's
go we got yeah after we got I think uh
after puckish Rogue we did puckish Rog
that's the last one we did I believe the
we got we got a time we got three time
emojis in the chat by Divi he's been a
member for 35 months uh then we got a $2
Super Chat for the angry therapist Duro
from uh VF was a beast with fighter yes
absolutely but she's not a robot got a
$10 super trat from uh sin vett I will
let the world burn aund uh a thousand
times before I play for fortnite over
Halo thank you put the fraud alert on
well the problem is then you going to
let the world burn because 100 million
people was lining up to play that I know
you had no problem jumping in on the
Halo yesterday yeah the funny part is
you guys are you guys are a minority in
this situation that is true you get off
my lawn face
ass Lang for the Lord day my bad I'm
sorry is too strong my bad my bad I
apologize this man love fortnite you say
super TR from doct Strange Love I know
you ain't disrespecting Cory B my head
yeah yes he did he's he's a I
disrespected coima so we're good uh
acting like he did something nice he
came over there after he just did remix
to Ether that's all he did he did what
y'all been do he and if y'all look at
Gears of War all he did was take god of
war and run behind stuff do same thing
like War what he did was look over at
somebody that was nice then he went and
he plagiarized the north mythology with
on it and then y got it he even throws a
hammer out there I mean it acts like
it's a hammer and it come back y'all
been bamboozled and think he's nice tell
him do something new get out of here
will say that I played uh the ending of
Ragnarok I was very underwhelmed by the
story of that game um then we got a $10
Super Chat from zip Davis a new K and
segment Cog out of out of context or coc
for short oh c on defining Duke 151 at 5
minutes and 33 seconds C says and I
quote I am a guy who likes a good
stuffing I did not say it
like yo he got me out of F I did not say
it like that you po they talking about
Thanksgiving and what's the best car
size and I said everybody like a good
stuer
pause everybody everybody you better
tell the truth to shame the devil call
on Twitter I am a guy who loves yo you
stupid continue they go they gonna get
those tapes on Twitter it's over it's
over shout out to uh one gifted
membership from Craig hooligan apprciate
that put the logos in the chat uh
welcome that one person into the realm
then we got $5 Super Chat from King is
overrated what's up Lords question I
want all of your predictions right now
for what's prise announcements you think
will be shown at the VGA I plead the
fifth plead the
fifth we good I he wants all of our I
say I say um I say lant Studios is being
purchased by Microsoft after they wi
Game of the Year Phil's gonna come out
get the award and say thank you and if y
thought you can stop me my bank thick
boy pause
pause uh let's go prediction three bit
what you think what announcements will
be shown at the VGA surprise
announcement uh Xbox got the rights to
Tomb Raider C
okay is it gonna be followed up they
bought Crystal Dynamics yeah
yeah he's like yeah yeah take that take
that take that take
that I'm going to go left field I'm I
think we're going to get like a switch
to little tweezer Pi of the new the
joystick or something like that just to
get us hyped up for
thewi G switch gang is outside coming in
h okay adct what was your uh prediction
saying bers G three in Game Pass keeping
it keeping it safe all right that's
right you no me and him hanging around
each other we start to think the
same see but the difference is is I was
realistic I say that when I'm listen
listen listen and this is where we have
the little uh devil on one side little
angel on the other we we talk on both
Sid don't worry about it
yeah the devil's on my shoulders more
realistic than the devil's on
your for me we Sega is definitely
teaching something that's a
topic I'm just going to say I'll say it
on the topic but I think it's going to
be something for the fighting community
and I'll save it for when time for the
topic next one Chris Jones C youit five
hour Super Chat he'll take yosha taka
morama junko kanana three bit and Casey
h as his team oh development Squad okay
three bit you been hired oh that's
what's up Chris Jones my man see you n
no doubt are we good are we caught
up yeah yeah
we all right we gonna finally get to
these topics in this an hour and 20
minutes in hey know I was holding it
down till you showed
up this is adex topic I can set him up
if he chooses or not what up to you you
can set it up all right so big week
obviously um started off with uh Tim
Stewart Xbox uh Chief Financial Officer
he um made some statements earlier
talking about um state of Game Pass and
where things are so excuse me he said
he's not announcing anything broadly but
um he says that Xbox mission is to bring
its first party experiences and
subscription services to every screen
that can play a game that means Smart
TVs mobile devices that means what we
would have thought as competitors in the
past like PlayStation and Nintendo we're
giving we're going to nvidia's GeForce
now their gaming subscription service
and he says the acquisition of ABK
allows Microsoft to bring its business
to these endpoints in a much faster way
compared to trying to do its own so this
set off a Tade of events and um the
thoughts at the time was kind of like
well regarding this is you know what's
the future of Xbox are they going third
party shout out to window Central Jaz
cor wait hold on Danny said we skipped
his $5 super Super Chat ad make sure you
get a chance when you get get to that no
we'll take care of look up for Danny
yeah look for Danny when we do that and
then um yeah man so then Shout Out J gon
from his article so he said he asked
Phil Spencer about Xbox cfo's Tim
Stewart's recent comments regarding Game
Pass and uh he said many Xbox fans took
that to indicate that Microsoft is
preparing for an industry where Xbox
Hardware no longer exists since Game
Pass and his exclusives are primary
value driver for series X so this is
what Phil had to say okay I got it I got
Danny passion yeah you want me to read
it real quick yeah real quick okay um
Danny passion the official for the $5
Super Chat Boulders Gate 3 online co-op
it sucks it shouldn't excuse me it
shouldn't be nominated as the best
multiplayer at the tgba I started
playing there with my wife and we had a
lot of issues sorry no okay so you don't
want that get that out of the nomination
it's not on my thing at all cuz I'm
looking and I can't find it don't worry
I got it I got it I appreciate it no
doubt don't doubt all right so Phil says
I'll start by saying we have no plans
bring game p to bring Game Pass to
PlayStation or Nintendo it's not in our
plans but I think you hit you hit on the
right point of what it means to own an
Xbox the things I want to be focused on
Is How We Do continue to innovate for
people who've made the commitment to our
Hardware platform and how do we continue
to make sure that they feel great about
their investment and what we've built
I'm obviously going to have my old point
of view on hard or Hardware but I think
Hardware teams or Hardware team did a
great job with the series X and the
series s this generation when I think
about investments in things like Game
Pass and xcloud G AC crossplay and cross
saave and ID at Xbox all of these things
I want us to continue to innovate so
people on our console feel like we're
making investments in cons consoles that
matches their commitment they're making
to us Game Pass is one of the things you
know that over the last 5 years we built
and we continue to grow it's on PC it's
on cloud it's an important part of the
Xbox console ident
and I think it will continue to be that
and we will continue to look at Future
ways for us to innovate across our game
portfolio and our platform so this kind
of shook the Earth again because now
Phil has directly responded to the you
know the narrative about x uh Xbox going
third party so adct this is your topic
this is a big one I know the adct show
you had a video gaming addict Channel
you had video what are your thoughts on
everything that's transpired in Phil
statement people need to stop jumping
out the window and making definitive
statements acting like they know the
industry better the people are actually
covering the industry half the time and
most of these people and what what
irritates me is like look I get it if
you generally thought this I don't like
you Wen you're not paying attention
you're not at all like you have some
kind of alternative motive now you can
look at the CFO statement and be like a
little like eye casing where it's like
uh you know I I get it but at the same
time like what they saying isn't what
they're doing in any way shape or form
and that's why like I I have an issue
with okay if you're going out there and
your and your brand is to talk down
other brands this is right on your queue
yeah this is what you've been waiting
this is what you woke up this morning
for are you implying that some people
have an agenda about the platform oh
yeah people got genders about every
platform but if you Kong will die you
call yourself a you know a a
non-bias ob objective and you know
you're supposed to you know see things
from both side of the the Spectrum both
side of the coins and the first thing
you did is make videos on this and the
first thing you did is is make articles
on this and like people should know
better like there's a different I know
people gonna say in the com but add you
made a video on it yeah but in no way
shaper for did I act like I knew what
was going on more than people actually
there covering it I went over what was
in gave you my input there there is some
click baity articles on the internet and
videos that they're making it seem like
people are there in the room they they
was they were signing the
papers it's like look I get it if that's
why I said if you generally are just
confused there's a difference between
that and just jumping out the window
like like people sitting there like oh
it it you know what's funny too I know
about to go to another side right hey
King King King talk to me sir uh for
years I've been told that um XBox
doesn't make impaling games and no one
wants them that's right tell the truth
Shan the devil so explain to me why
everyone was celebrating their games
come into game their games coming to
Playstation who cuz cuz they thought
they was GNA get the gear forer and and
and Halo but somebody said hell
no Bessie Bessie to me it's just like
look like you know what the CFO said I I
do feel like you can question in fanish
but yeah but at the same time it's like
people people that's been covering this
industry for for decades and the first
thing you do is go out and make tweets
and stuff you just you not being genuine
you cloud and and you know I get it
people like B adct you know websites uh
you know YouTube channels they they
gener off of traffic and that's easy
traffic but then that's where integrity
is in
play because you can like for instance
you could easily just make a video going
over what he said and say you know what
let's let's take a step back and find
out how this unwinds let's what kind of
tax is that oh it's it's an Xbox
tax here we go here we go cuz all I know
and maybe it's just me all I know is if
something like this happened you know on
the blue side of the industry we go
personally feel like the Not only would
there be less coverage on it there would
be more coverage defending why shouldn't
happen like they was doing when they
lost all those movies yeah I actually I
didn't really see no one talking about
that no yeah I got you but but K tell me
exact tell me
exactly you know what I'm I'm I'm G let
you go King cuz I'm just going to keep
going in circles I I don't agree with
how the industry handled this
I I feel
like there's no Integrity in anything
anymore if people feel like they can
gain a buck they they will gain a buck
and you know it's just it's sad man
because it's like you know I'm sitting
here looking at this and first off
people on Twitter looking wild coming
out with these these these crazy
statements and I'm just like yeah that
ain't gonna age
will it's just it's funny man it's funny
you know at the end of the
day Microsoft has done nothing to make
you think that they're third party King
how long has people been saying they're
going third party for 20
years since we started covering this
stuff theyve saying 360 when they was
getting they nose B popped off when they
bought all those Studios first thing I
heard is oh they're going third party
then they bought Bethesda oh they're
going third party then they bought ABK
oh they're going third party third party
there is third party already right now
King King if if they were going third
party
would they have cared what kind of
deal PlayStation would have been signing
n they made them bend the knee that was
good though yeah because to me if they
were going third party this is just to
me if they were going third party when
they we uped to sign that deal they
excluded everything else but Call of
Duty if everything was going to
PlayStation why would they care that's
what I'm talking
about but I mean that's I mean that's
you you talking with a brain right yeah
obviously that that's something that
people lack people are running on hot
steam these days they don't the Mindless
zombies the Mindless zombies they they
they they they sheep yeah sheep the
Sheep the Sheep are we good are we good
sir there's a bunch of hold my pockets
going on Twitter right now oh man that's
crazy that's pocket holder so man if you
got your bars off I'll open this up if
if you got your bars off would be
respectful no well tell we got guests we
got guest he said he want he said I want
King to get him
now save it up addict shout to L 3 bit
man uh obviously this was a big week
with uh Tim Stewart CFO comments in
reference to his vision and then
obviously you know Phil now has the kind
of GRA gamebreaking internet breaking
interview with jez Cordon in reference
to the plans moving forward what are
your thoughts on all of this yeah so I I
made a post the the day this happened or
the day the sea started talking and I
think it's really important to listen
listen to the entire interview it's
really easy to get Snippets because if
you do a lot of the information or
either things they really already
mentioned in the past of how they're
going to handle the Xbox platform uh it
kind of goes into the context of where
how they're going to handle ABK rather
than a general thing of all all Xbox
games or all third party um and and to
me they want to expand game pass onto
other screens which Phil disuss MH and
that that's proven with with the deal
they had with like stuff like Samsung so
you can play game pass on your TV um and
Xbox already they already approached
Nintendo and Sony in the past to to try
and get game pass on their devices and
they and as expected they're both like
nah I don't I don't pass on my thing
right so Xbox is trying to expand in a
market that is closing them off so like
how hard was it to get game pass onto an
apple right because Apple they wanted
you to buy every single game in order to
access it through their store which
obviously doesn't work in the context of
Game Pass so Xbox found a way around
that you're like hey let's make it
accessible through the browser um and
Sony even went as far in my opinion to
take out the brow the browser uh so Game
Pass wouldn't be functional on their
devices uh ins slated for like a
security reason right so they've been
already trying to expand their services
in a competitive market um um that wants
to close off their ecosystems and we
we've heard about the thing with King
for example right what did Phil say he
said one of the one of the reasons they
wanted to buy ABK was King so mobile um
not King David King mobile king mob no I
mean we come we par in parel we come
part part P yes uh so yeah so why would
Xbox One invest in Mobile it's just it's
because the the console Market is
stagnant it it does
grow as much as the is not enough you
say it's not enough to me I don't think
it's enough you know so you're fighting
for the same users every single
generation and out of PC and and and
mobile and I'm get to my point it's it's
the smallest market so when people say
like Xbox can't afford to do exclusives
or they don't care about them when the
console is the smallest Market I'm just
like it doesn't make much sense to me
right and and when we see examples of
titles that are are now exclusive
Starfield being one right and then you
had outer Worlds 2 which was previously
on all platforms correct and the next
one is exclusive you had hellblade 2
which was a PlayStation exclusive that
sequel is only on Xbox he you even had
the FTC court case where Xbox uh admit
like as soon as they got Bethesda
they're like they told them to go to
Disney and change their contracts to
make sure Indiana Jones is exclusive
they took yeah three but they took Rec
Court they're like that's ours we we we
fight for like that's ours so when
people say XBox doesn't care about
exclusives I'm just like what and then
you even had the the brutal email of
Matt booty telling hey we're gonna
outspend PlayStation say it again say it
again hold on you was you was a little
bit low we are going to outspend
PlayStation out of business yes yes
that's what I that that's what I meant
through but when I was like people that
just jumped out that out that window
without much thought process they're not
paying attention or they don't or
they're paying attention but it doesn't
fit their narrative it doesn't fill up
their their their Penny bank I feel
exctly in in in fairness I mean the CFO
does does make a statement that says you
know that they want their stuff on
Playstation Nintendo so can we see
already on Playstation Nintendo right
but my question is for three pit like do
you see how maybe it could be
misconstrued for for you it's definitive
based on the other factors that you're
saying yeah I mean I I feel like if they
had the opportunity to put game pass on
Playstation they would do it right in a
hot second they they would do it but as
of now I think exclusives are still
important to their model I mean the guy
who just said they're going to spend
outspend PlayStation out of business is
now in charge of the studios with his
promo
right the guy that want you die it's in
charge I'm just say you guys are in
trouble ridiculous yeah so I mean it is
what it is like that's the thing when
when people are talking about Xbox I
feel like a lot of them are talking from
an outside lens and not really taking
those things into consideration not
really taking the context of of what
Phil has stated in the past of like um
of basically when Phil was B basically
like all these games wherever Game Pass
is is where you you can find these games
like he said that because the same
situation happened like the only reason
he had to bring that up is like all
right listen we're not going to put
everything on every platform where Game
Pass Legacy titles that's when they
started talking about that because the
same exact situation happened where
they're like every single game is going
third party from Xbox so I don't know I
I take those things into consideration I
I can understand
from his statements you're like oh oh
all Xbox games are are third party but a
majority of like ABK games I'm sure will
be third party right you got Call of
Duty uh OverWatch and stuff but hey it's
not guaranteed the other ones I don't
really know what their plans are for uh
ABK but I don't know no I get it no I I
get where you're coming from I get where
you come from you kind of you're kind of
implying like um live service in a sense
right that that kind of makes sense
to kind of keep that but maybe
everything else does not no I I he we
going three bit I hear put down lord mm
man I'm curious like um obviously it's
been a tumultuous week on the socials
everyone's very strongly about one way
is Xbox going third party if it's not
you know what did you take from Tim
Stewart's comments and then obviously
Phil Spencer's comments with Jess gton
yeah I mean it's obvious that the CFOs
the money man he's going to talk about
where the most money can be generated
and that's you know as people say that
like the life service games they're
going everywhere they have to that's
that's like what they've been doing for
all these years there's no way they're
going to just sap all that Revenue out
of nowhere but I think most people
forget that Xbox is already a third
party publisher and so is Sony by the
way I don't know if you know a game I
think it's America's pastime I think
it's called MLB something show ml the
show that's a first party Studio that's
a first party Studio yeah we launching
game well how many how many years has it
been in gay pass now I don't know maybe
this next year's one is coming so like
is a third party publish don't let
anyone tell you otherwise the only one
who's not is Nintendo because you know
they're doing their own thing but uh but
yeah yeah just like just to just to
reiterate that and I think it's
important also just to recognize that
the the exclusives is what's going to
help Game Pass grow and they want it to
grow just across all platforms so
they're they're putting it everywhere
like on GeForce now we saw all the
agreements they signed with all these um
Cloud providers in Europe as
after a decade is now on
Nintendo who did that for you who did
that for
you Phil Dominus Maximus aelia
Spencer you spend 70 billion to be a
third party come on let's come on let's
let's beic about that what's funny is we
we were hearing the same conversation
when Bethesda was bought oh they you
know they they need PlayStation's money
because they spent $7 billion Starfield
quote unquote is definitely going to be
on PlayStation and winded up happening
like all these games have been ever
since those initial games that was
designed to come to both everything else
has been exclusive even redfall like
it's just like the the part that
irritates me is that this is this is
when I look at the Xbox Tech scenario do
I think the entire industry is coming
together to like to clown on Xbox or to
mustache to attack Xbox yeah I I don't I
don't think it's that but I I I do think
that there are people in the industry
that the moment even a little bit that
they're able to sit on Xbox they they
they are doing it they they are on top
they they they looking for a reason
they're like oh we got them we got
trying they're trying to deficate on
Xbox messy anyway but that's it mm I
hear I hear what you're putting down I
hear what's going on Lord King God help
us what what do you think about Tim
Stewart's comments you know the CFO it's
the CFO they gonna say k it's the CFO
saying what he's saying and then man
Phil dominis comes outside you know and
says he does not have those plans so so
what do you said I learn the game from
William Wesley you can never check me
not the not the on these
toon y yo yo J dub tweet wasn't even
warm it was still hot off the pressence
Phil say spin the block I got these D
roll down the
window they sitting on the
sto out L you in
chalk
you here
lies are you are you saying Xbox boys in
the hood Jay dub running
they said run Ricky run oh man three bit
get your in three bit get your out the
window and
said he said that's d right
there that's d right
there crazy how fast that was that was
quick that was
quick it's like the projectiles come out
was the Bethesda game ABK n he hit them
with Popeye's biscuits in the mouth poop
in the mouth oh man I I could just see I
could just see a meme right now on
Twitter with Phil Spencer with the the
Bazooka play Xbox series X and it just
it's just looking out the car and it
shows jayb running away from the car
shout out to J said wait till you get a
load of
me yo YouTu like yo time out this shout
out to Tim Stewart all right so a lot of
you morons and that's what I like to use
I like to use morons because you're not
using your brain to the fullest let's
let's let's use your brain to the
fullest right so he's talking to
investors y'all not D to invest anything
y y'all y'all are
consumers the only thing they invested
is they time on Twitter they got to
understand it's this side and it's this
side true the people that make things
happen and you the things that help
things along right so the help thing
along people y'all thought that this was
going to help y'all get to where y'all
wanted to be but the investors need to
know you got to see the difference
between you and them is y'all fall for
anything investors don't so you got to
just give them a Rosy outlook on how the
world looks so they can feel comfortable
with coming up off those billions out of
their pockets so these are trillionaires
talking to investors that are
trillionaires noce Sony wasn't in the
room cuz they're billionaires they're on
the side so they wasn't talking to
Twitter okay he wasn't talking to you
dudes so y' dudes happen to ease drop in
the room oh a they talking about putting
their GES everywhere oh right yo they
wanted to be on our Jo so y'all didn't
want the ABK deal to go through because
y didn't want us to really compete now
that we really competing like oh y
really bu that that's illegal y That's a
monopoly that's a monopoly we got to
block this I see I see these people uh
King on Twitter is like gaming Kens like
no not like that not like that we don't
want you to compete like that Dad just
complete like us like do it like us do
do how we
compete no we going to do it how we
compete $2 wallets right so the Big B
little B all I can hear all I can hear
is say oh no what did we do check it out
so they get the ABK right y'all thought
y was getting star because they need our
monies they need our mone's because we
can like he told yall step it up right
get over here so all right so they see
this CFO come out y'all thought
Starfield was going to show up on your
box we got hope people y'all had the
Jesse Jackson face the fifth pump in the
air y'all was like yeah it's coming over
here Phil came out spin the block and
said Popeye's biscuits for you Popeye
biscuits for you we told y'all when we
was in our infancy did you want to get
down they said hey do you want to sh a
lunch and y'all said nah man get out of
here your lunch whack then you see the
the smage B that he got now y' like hey
hey King I got I got a different
scenario Phil Phil got a hit list after
all that going down he got like one of
those those trucks that you uh that you
open the back and they'll get in front
of the open the back but in in instead
of it being something that just St a
bunch of popey
biscuits and they like shot it go go go
go so so now that y'all see the smish B
and y'all see what's being offered y'all
want in I'm glad Phil came through and
said no right no now for the investors
listen yall going to get uh Call of Duty
Wars I told you that that was gonna be
y'all that's y'all Y hold that y oh hold
that um Diablo not that as a game of
service you get that anything that we
can rip money out your pockets on a
constant basis you will get that but if
you think you getting our single player
have fun narrative games no that's not
for your D governor
oh man that's the C UK King so right now
y' got your own troubles to worry about
and the fact that y'all third party
already first of all y'all our first
party boo boo we like you m mo the show
can't wait to open a day that's day and
day I don't pay so they working for you
now yeah but yeah you know how they
do it's going to be a day where we look
over and y'all expiring all right cuz
y'all expiring at a you feel like you're
hoping and wishing for this day oh yes
yes I'm biased as hell like I tell dudes
to their face like I really want y'all
to
go and and and this is how we gonna get
all your games on Xbox because yall
gonna be an app and we gonna click the
app and we gonna play God of War we
gonna play Spiderman and we GNA have fun
and why y'all really scared is y'all can
know that could really happen like y'all
know it could really happen so y'all
thought the CFO was going to give you
Lifeline Phil had to come and
said that these dudes don't understand
real English so I got to say it to them
in real English popey's biscuits for you
and I'm glad that he did it in less than
24 hours this has been the best clack
back um outlin and chalk I see all your
Twitter pages right now y outline and
chalk they jumped out the window too
early that's what it was oh yeah yeah
they broke both their kneecaps cuz they
put the blanket away
move Mo they jumped out the window know
they had a mattress and somebody mov a
mattress and they all broke their legs
and I love the fact that yall laying
there on the ground no third
party work hey you know one thing I will
say King maybe it's just me did did you
get tagged in any jab du tweets when
that hell no hell no when I went back at
him he forgot who we were keing you
should F away yo after after I snuffed
him Phil came around the box and put a
Biscuit in my P I was like here you go
take that don't m with him don't come
for the king unless he s for you
bye all right yeah
um clearly the king feels how the king
feels um oh we got 14 uh we got uh
1,000 hit the like button yo y'all walk
in yeah wipe your feet at the door
please that's that like button subscribe
and share it out because why are you
hoarding this to yourself you heard all
of that right there that was fun as hell
and we got L Stanfield and we got no
don't do we do not have L Stanfield we
have three B cting that's K cting oh yo
you do we got our Dubai brother sing
from Dubai and my mood over here no you
ain't call him
s Soo listen we game up
God B rain we not doing that shout out
to my home you know
what's people you know the same people
writing those articles about you know
Xbox going third party they're going to
they're going to make articles about
these people actually on the iron Lord's
podcast such
such gon be say they're gonna be saying
Le
Stanfield I can't his agent's like what
the
heck he probably in the chat
like oh man y'all M
be he looks so much like actually
contact him like why would you on the
show to
tell get your agent get your agent It
Was it crazy that that people's
messaging went from Xbox is going full
third party to Xbox is leaving the
console business to Xbox is doing bad
financially like that that was like all
happened within the span of like a day
was that Starfield put put put put some
put some heat on them man they they they
they they were running away Starfield
was like getting random Strays that
running left and right like everyone
thought they was good they couple miles
away and Bam they hit in the
head it was it was a crazy starfields
reach was
magnificent you did he uh what did he
say oh he was at Brazil how many players
I think uh it was
like 125 something something like that
shout out to shout out to Phil on that
one but look you know I jump in um yeah
I'm I'm with King on this part it's it's
the audience right and it's it's
investors versus you know the gaming
audience and
however I will push back a little bit I
do understand the perception of mixed
messaging because even though we get it
right I can understand to King's Point
if someone's listening into the Wells
Fargo investment situation from CFO and
they hear those comments I can see how
that can get misconstrued totally
understand that yeah so shout out to
Phil for realizing that and shout out to
jez for making it happen to set the
record straight for the gaming and the
overall future those who follow the
platform three bit you said it like
based on the actions that we've seen
right hellblade Starfield you know all
the tangible evidence as of right now
and in the immediate future this a third
party Xbox thir going through probably
makes no sense because the actions don't
justify it minus two or three outliers
which is what we say like a Minecraft
and now we know Call of Duty based on
the the court case and stuff like that
so again to me it's they clearly have
some type of exclusives plan because if
they didn't they would be okay let's
just sign the everything like they
didn't they they deliberately said you
just getting Call of Duty now you had
the chance but now we locking stuff down
so you have to sign the Call of Duty one
yeah investors they all they understand
is okay like King said how much money
can we get out of this right so you
appease them by telling them about a
Call of Duty and a Minecraft oh why that
that's a future that could go everywhere
but those are outliers that that does
not represent the entire thing and then
Phil also made a comment about you know
their investment to the hardware future
with the promotion of sarahan who's also
has Hardware as part of her um you know
responsibilities and stuff like that and
their dedication to it now again I
cannot predict the future 10 years down
the road Anything could happen I mean we
could go to a part where they go third
party or we have a situation where
everyone's wall Garden you know comes
down but I will say this if that's the
case and people are third party I know
who's best equipped based on their
service to be able to facilitate that
and it would be Xbox in that case so
again I understand it but I I do have to
I do feel like if you've been paying
attention and you look at the actions
like we like three again you know we
talked about a the worlds we talk about
staria we talk about hellblade 2 look at
the next year's lineup look at
everything from this point on they have
made a decision oh um the red fall and
star oh yeah take that off that that
that's coming here you know what I'm
saying like they've made internal
decision we've seen the documentation
where things are being made we found out
with Indiana Jones right that oh by the
way yeah contracts the contracts yeah
that's ours we're going to amend you out
so if you if you are going third party
you're not making these attempts to for
for to promote exclusivity because the
exclusivity is helping people bring to
that service that you want you want to
make that service which is Game Pass
diverse and have content to make you
stay in they only for and also from the
investor standpoint what is really
appealing to them is even if it's one
game like a I don't know Minecraft or
agent Empire but you stay in that game
you live in that game you you're doing
as far as microtransactions or
engagement you're consistently on it
that appeals to them you know the rest
of the stuff is is you know kind of in a
different way which is accessibility to
the point where it'd be hard to ignore
Game Pass like right having a service is
like Game Pass where you're like oh wow
look at the value look at the value
proposition right can I do no absolutely
right and where King is right it's just
like people have to stop with this the
way we do it is the right way and the
only way right and I get the traditional
model the console model I get it and I
understand a lot of people think that is
the only way for Success the way Sony
does it or Nintendo does it is the only
way they are not operating the same way
and I know even though I struggle with
it bu is
well it's yeah too but it's just it's a
concept that is new to us because again
they talk about like kind of like a what
it's a high-end Market they consider
subscriptions and services the high-end
Market that's what they're they're not
looking at the the consoles and how much
more because again like you said mmon as
well it's a lowend ceiling it's you're
fighting for the same people over and
over it's like it's yeah it's like
living in the project yeah you fighting
for the same blocks it's the same three
people it's the the same three gangs
fighting over the same block every
generation right and you get the same
individuals what Microsoft is doing is
opening up and again I'm not more
expensive every time as well exact and
and here's the thing I want to be clear
I'm not saying consoles are irrelevant
and you don't need them I'm not saying
that but for them and their model it's
one piece of the pie it is not the
entire pie for them and that's why I
think people are really struggling to
understand because they're so used to
the tried andr tradition console model
kind of thing I mean I remember that
backlash with with uh Xbox and PC when
when they first
start the media backlash against that
they're like what you're you're opening
it up to PC to like no exclusives
anymore like I remember when that was a
big deal that was a big deal and and
let's be honest for us it was a little
bit of a culture shock cuz again we're
used to the console and that's it and
then it's like okay in see what it is is
the Hardcore we got to we got to be real
y we we are a we are a need we are a we
are not the major it's like how I'm
resisting King and addict with fortnite
they telling me the real though that's
what's going on as far as the player and
the engage so what I'm saying is the
hardore not that you're going to go away
but the reality is mobile you know where
uh PC all these other avenues where
there's a screen that you can access it
right that's part of their their Vision
that that's just it is okay the only
thing I I I just want to say cuz I know
everybody the only thing I just want to
say is the the quicker way to die is to
constrict yourself to one demographic
that you continue to sell to one hustle
right it's one hustle you so but you
you're noticing that these indigo
children is not interested in in
engaging how you want them to engage
which is what Jim Ryan has been saying
right so the trend has already been
shown that the more screams that you can
get the attention of the Indigo child
they don't want the Gray beard they
already got us right right we yeah we
are the fools that will continue to buy
but the Indigo child you have to gain
their attention in a way that talks to
them and they're so different and unique
bro I got to interrupt you you on fire
did you see that metric that came out
that said kids right now want
subscription Services the most and
digital over consoles yes they don't
want a console because they can they
their phone is the console their tablet
is the console like you know what's
funny I I saw another one where it was a
I think it was like a company like a
contracted company that goes to these
events and the first day they had two
controllers and like U an iPad to to
access this game and by the fifth day of
the event they removed all of the
controllers and had three iPads and a PC
because a lot lot of people would come
up to it and didn't know how to use a
controller they're so used to touchpads
it was the younger audiences it's a
different demographic and and again who
now I get it we're smaller we have a lot
of disposable income but this next
generation of Gamers like adak saying
like you're saying King it's a different
energy and I know it's scary for some to
think about but they have to prepare for
themselves for that potential future and
that audience and if you lock yourself
to one hustle you could be the Great
greatest at that one hustle right
whether it be Sony Nintendo but if the
market goes that way and you still
selling old product an old way you're
out of here it's like you still bumping
CDs outside yeah you you like do we see
the mixtape dude at the corner anymore
remember remember they table outside to
go out there and see if they got the new
50 Cent you you got the new 50 Cent yeah
exactly so so people kill me when they
be like console's the the way that's the
bro I get it for now that may be it for
now
2.6 billion people yeah bro that's the
money people and again it's just all I
try to tell people because I know it's
an emotional thing for a lot of people
it's emotion it's we we I call it an
inflection point people are we're in
this point where they're seeing it and
people are scared to death and that's
why a lot of this stuff is is coming out
because people don't want to be we all
think the way we did it is the best
let's just be honest right us all had
you know this the way you do it saying
we was L bro it's addict generation it's
these kids that that's what's going on
it's even further than that F than that
these indigo children brother yeah is is
the Z is that and I and listen it's okay
it's okay to be scared the key is that
for right now the last point I'll say is
that what I like and we have tangible
proof that in the immediate future at
least on the Xbox side consoles are not
going away they understand the
technology right now was still not there
with flying cars in perfect latency you
know what I'm saying so it'll be an
add-on right you can still do it but
there's still going to be a need for the
traditional Native market right that's
fine we do know CU they business out in
the street that there is another console
that hybrid 2020 so we're getting
another generation right now what
happens you know let's say that let's
this is one at last is eight or whatever
and then the next one lasts six to seven
or eight think there'll be another one
right now after that I can't predict it
ain't going
PlayStation I think last Next Generation
is going to be the the last generation
for both platforms for Xbox cuz they
going to be there but there ain't going
to be no PlayStation sex it's a I think
they both will be apps by like 20 34
2035 it's a possibility but again no one
you're ridiculous no one can predict the
future no one can except King except k k
predict he's got it locked down but
that's all I got unless anybody else got
anything else they want to add to no
I'll just I'll just point to Fuzzy's
comment where he said physical media
diss are on their way out and I I
believe that that too I mean a lot of
the things in the Xbox one generation
are now common things nowadays like
their modern-day expectations for the
most part A lot of the stuff that they
introduced in Xbox one that a lot of
people sort of backlashed against and
sort of push back now it's like an
expectation with certain devices so our
Evolution as uh uh of consoles and where
we're headed it's it's always going to
evolve and uh we'll see we'll see I I
don't put I don't get physical media
anymore unless cool statue or something
for the most part but I I it's too much
work for me to get up put a disc in I
don't know I used to be that dude I used
to be the midnight launch guy and you go
out there and then they say yo you can
download it from the crib and I ain't
got to stand online and it was over it
was over for me I I know how it is it's
got so bad they don't even do midnight
releases any
sometimes when like I don't want to wait
for that game to download like if the
cuz sometimes preloads don't work
correctly I'm like nah I'm I'm gon go
get it from GameStop and I'll call like
4te like is any GameStop uh doing
midnight releases before I call my
actual yeah uh my uh my local GameStop
he's like nah man like I think they did
a a tears of the Kingdom one but besides
that that's the only one I can remember
them doing yeah yeah it was a fun time
it was a fun time but anyway anyway
that's all I got you want to get the
super chats add it get those lined up
while I get things
ready
next to yall in chat salute to y'all
rocking up in there a thousand hit 400
hit that like button we ain't even got
500 ain't even half of Y half of y'all
are playing
around something something's going on
with the super chats cuz people keep
saying we're missing Super Chat
no but no it's it's it's not showing up
on um on my list like I'm have to go to
like the actual director yeah you got to
go to directory what I'll do is I'll try
to you want me to just try to get some
you want me to wait cuz um yeah just
start where I went off and I will okay
Lucius Augustus the last one the member
Super Chat uh I know Cedric H we had
truck all right so we last hour remember
was Danny P passion official we he said
the Skip and then we had Cedric H shout
out to him he had um gifted 10 IR law
podcast membership salute salute then we
got truckle chuckle 2B Super Chat sorry
to interrupt but you missed my two super
chats we're on it we're on it something
with the fan funding on YouTube is is
acting wrong cuz it's not showing
everything who said that that we missed
our super CH truckle
chuckle salute to him and then I'll get
Lucius Augustus member for 27 months
salute the media suddenly forgetting
what Phil has stated many times now just
seems malicious how is that not an Xbox
tax three bit I'll let you guys to
that people call me the tax collector
yeah you're the tax collector all the
stuff I've been saying about the Xbox
tax I think with in this specific
scenario it's probably just a mixture of
of things I do believe it's a little bit
of the Tex but I also think just if
you're not within the Xbox ecosystem I
think Co said it uh pretty good like if
you're not in the Xbox ecosystem you're
not seeing all the things that they've
done uh with the FTC where they want to
put games exclusive where they announced
like Elder Scrolls is probably going to
be exclusive things like that I
understand uh if you're not in the Xbox
EOS system and you just hear those
comments you're just like oh they're
going multiplat but it does take context
to in my opinion to write that article
like because he was talking about ABK
and where they're headed with those G so
it does take a lot of
context you sound like they some need
reading comprehension that's what it
sound like my sound like ni's
you see you see how he smoothly try to
say people are not intelligent that was
smooth I like how he did that theef is
ill he's ill with it I'm going do this
really I'mma do this uh swiftly because
I I don't want people missing their
super chats um I'm just read all I see
because it's not a lot realistic $5
draft from Pony up Pony
up hope Xbox terms are more attainable
than Sony given their focus on building
out a legacy see marketplace with OG 360
it would seem uh self-defeating
otherwise we got a $2 Che from Robert
kellet blessed day Lords excited for the
ad $50 Super Chat from uh Hood ninja
yeah we got him uh okay uh $2 shipping
trat from Pony
up that's that's a king fan it's got to
be King
David take it to the pH uh uh the Phil
streets I don't know no don't say that
don't say that that that's controversial
yeah yeah that's
controversial that's politics we ain't
doing that $20 super trap from Hood
ninja any reviewer who said Starfield
has a a new game plus they are exposed
they either have to admit release he's
just trying to catch Gap Dr stranga
please don't let adate the Super Chat I
got some bad news for you we got a $5
Super Chat from let's play with each
other's joystick I am not reading that
cuz I know that was read $2 Nintendo
Dawn theotaku fortnite game with the
generation it's undeniable $2 from
Doctor Strange Love I'm no side Mill
King I'm the main course for solve got a
five $10 super tra from Hood ninja my
point is New Game Plus uh the narrative
restarts you repeat the narrative in
this game the story actually continues
they call at your action from previous
univers Todd hid that to call out
reviewers $5 Super Chat from uh puke is
Rogue 100 Punk is Rogue 100 who's the
best robot fighter did you guys that one
$2 Super Chat from the angry therapist
DL from okay we read that one too okay I
think this is where we started missing
uh uh
truckle with the five Super Chat
apologies Cog but I believe it was a
sausage party sprinkled to some Advanced
g y y that's funny as hell did Cog leave
yes he he left he left he he he read
that5 $5 Super Chat from uh robot OCT
octopus Co I gotta know have you caught
blue ey Samurai on Netflix yet it's
hands down the beefiest thing I've seen
on Netflix this year y it's dope bluee
Samurai is dope I just started watching
it's dope $10 Super Chat from sin
Vendetta I will let the world burn a 100
times over before I play fortnite over
Halo $2 from Nintendo Taco um Cog I had
a late patreon question $2 Super Chat
from Doctor Strange Love I know you
ain't disrespecting Corey ballock $ five
$10 Super Chat from zip Davis and new
Kan oh we I I read that $5 chat from
Kings overrated what's up Lords question
I got all your predict okay I read that
$5 chat from Chris
Jones I'll take no Cog read that uh $2
Super Chat from Dan passion official you
skipped my super chat I read that $2
Super Chat from truckle sorry to
interrupt but you missed my two Super
Chat I I caught them up a $5 Super Chat
from Champagne Nova Xbox acting like a
humble eight they need to show out at
the game awards to get haters on board
PlayStation is an overconfidence six
with a long
back
whoa yes super $10 St from King is
overrated if you look at both uh Xbox
and Playstation as a primary PC player
Xbox actually cares and releases their
games with PC in mind having to wait for
Sony to catch up with the library on PC
says a lot well that's Nexus Nexus has
uh too much under their belt that they
working on right
now5 Xbox is third party they are
already the biggest publisher today once
they buy Sega the the dam will burst
Sony and Nintendo will get wet no
worries that partnership is coming up
y'all see that
soon from Geek and geek to snake uh AO I
don't know which he was referring to
there and another $2 Super Chat from uh
trle is agree with Cog arcanes were once
best in games or something like that uh
okay then a $2 Super Chat from Cory
Tidwell we got King check your DMs and
then that's all all right Cory Tidwell
check my DMs what's going
[Laughter]
anyway oh we all right so we are going
to move oh I'm sorry you good yeah I
think I'm going to bounce right now all
right brother so yeah so thanks guys for
having me on uh if you guys don't want
to be harvested for SEO if you guys
don't want to be click baited and carled
support Independent Media like you know
just go out there read our content and
join the team and I'll see you guys next
time.net all right I can't I can't
retweet this mm you got see this before
you leave let me uh let me reread this
cuz uh he said it was addressed to you
you walked away right after wait hold on
hold on wait what's going on what's
going on oh they're so fast yo they fast
they are fast I pinned it up on the
screen they fast with wow that's crazy
it's not run Ricky run we got to um I
want to read this real quick me sorry
o octopus Cog I got to know have you
caught blueeyed Samurai on Netflix yet
it's hands down the beefiest thing I've
seen on Netflix this year it's dope it's
I heard it's crazy I heard it's crazy I
got to check it out for sure for sure
thank you for putting me
on yeah that's we're caught up and then
truckle didn't truckle say something or
he good oh no I I I read all I read all
the super chat cuz I know I I got up and
I heard somebody they said stuff to me
when I got up but anyway all right so
look we got the the moon send that send
that Meme to me uh King all right I am
so we got kind of M we got a multi-topic
shout out to um let's see we got uh Sega
man sega's in the building right now a
lot of stuff being rumored a lot of
cryptic stuff so it looks like Sega is
sending cryptic letters to Twitch
streamers urging them to watch the game
awards and I believe um it's one uh user
I believe her name name is curious joy
and I believe she uh follows she twitch
streamer that does jrpg games fighting
games things that nature and there was
like a card and it kind of was like
pretty much saying hey check it out um
it says um a new era the card says a new
era new energy make sure to tune in to
the Game of Wars December 7th so yeah
Sega you know kind of hitting they're
going to do something um unrelated or
related sarahan has also tweeted um this
is you know about the Sonic movie who's
going to see Sonic on the big screen um
everb Saga had to let me know quickly
you know I'm saying this is going down
you know what I'm saying so you got that
and then um this what I thought was kind
of interesting the legend Peter Moore we
had in the realm recently this year
twice actually and um he had some just
like a random last night tweet it was it
was him on stage you know from back in
the day saw like a 360 logo we saw Sega
logo we saw Unity EA so everybody's like
what is going on is any of this related
what is Sega doing what do we think it
is so three bit where where you at with
this uh Sega stuff I'm wondering if uh
they mentioned their super game I don't
know if this has anything to do with
that but hey um when has Sega made an
announcement like this prior to the TGs
I can't specifically remember if they
did this before so it it seems like
could be that super game they're talking
about uh if I was doing to do a fan
thing of what I would want out of Sega
then I want Sonic Adventure I want with
that Adventure okay okay that's what I
want that's what I want no doubt yeah
I'm guessing it's that super game all
right super game super game Lord ad man
sayga out here cryptic tweets and
sending stuff what do you think it is
what do you
want I think it's going to be some
fighting game I have absolutely zero uh
desire to play um but yeah but if I had
my way it' be that Persona six popping
up on that track that's I doubt it
because apparently it's like I keep up
with some of the like YouTube channels
that cover Persona and like all of them
are saying that right now Persona 6 is
scheduled for 2025 M but they don't know
when they're going to like reveal it MH
uh so you know they could reveal it at
the Video Game Awards uh part of me
feels
like it's going to be
interesting where that shows up more
than
anything I want it to show up at an Xbox
show clearly clearly yeah because I
think that there there would be no more
better victory over Saul than it show
you Xbox to as well sick you know but I
would take a Sonic Adventure 3 uh but I
don't I don't think I don't to this day
I I remember that like Escape From the
City s and stuff
had a great soundtrack yeah but I don't
part of me feels like they're done with
that AOS Sonic I I feel like they're
probably going to push more towards the
frontier Direction and I actually even
though I didn't play that game notice
what I did there Alex even though I
didn't play that game um I I do I do
think sh that what I saw of it looked
really good as a foundation to build on
the Sonic bran
iack yeah
so so I'm hoping that you know they they
do really good with it I really do I I
feel like Frontier has uh you know a
future if it's done correctly you know
there's a lot of other stuff didn't they
make Fantasy Star
too oh yeah yeah trying to think of all
the the franchises that they have a ton
they have a ton and I have a ton that
works in Game
Pass yeah kly King seems like he's to
talk what are your thoughts I think
there's a lot of stuff I think there's a
lot of stuff and for people in the chat
me and Al your friends relax I was
taking Jabs at him yesterday Live on a
show obviously your friends you out
there danc with pepperonis
out hey my pepperoni wasn't out that
time hey you see you got you got plans
for your pepperonis hey
yo
continue you
good oh I know yeah Ken your thoughts
man what do you feel what is Sega
hinting at okay so look at this Grand
conspiracy oh Lord all right all right
Grand conspiracy you still got Timeout
on screen all right it left all right so
check it out check it out Sarah B needs
to put her stamp on this right and Phil
Dominus Maximus really Spenser I mean
come and he got names like he got names
off of putting his stamp down he you see
his Footprints in the Sand you see what
he's done he has erected monuments he
has done this thing this is
him so to come after that like you know
Dave chel just came off the
stage and Cat Williams was going up the
catw wom's got a kill you understand
Dave Dave Chelle brought the house down
so here you go catw wom's up there this
is the part where she's going to make
her name known we already been seeing
her hunting at Sega she's been working
with Sega for a long period of time a
lot of this stuff a lot of those inroads
that she's done all those games that
y'all see the yaku's and all that stuff
that y'all see that I personally would
think that is attributed to her due
diligence in the Land of the Rising Sun
talking to Sega and seeing exactly what
was going on and what did they need to
get done and I think that they said okay
yo let's give us one more Shout with the
Sonic Allstar we're gonna try to fight
the champion one last time we're gonna
try to go out there and then she's like
all right you know what I'm saying you
know when your son gonna get beat up but
but you you got to let him go out there
you know what I'm saying like I would
tell you to you know get your brothers
and jump them but he's like nah I got to
go do this all right go ahead go do he
got molly wed he got smacked around he
got beat up and and and he come back in
the house Sega hole in his head like I
try I've been doing this for years and
put the hand on his back and said listen
Sega look at young Sega don't worry
about it we got
you we gonna put y'all in Game Pass we
gonna work this out because in Game Pass
you would have survived and you would
have beat that plumber you would you
would have got that plumber this time
like all right so what we going to do so
they're going to do a partnership I
think this is the time that you're gonna
hit a partnership with Microsoft and
Sega this is reasonable right and and I
think this is the time they're not gonna
go buy them oh all right I think because
I think it's it's more of a hassle to
buy Sega oh no you remember in the king
Chronicles yes he he's went away from
the Sega purch this is like super
reasonable no he went away from the Sega
purchasing to buying Square Unix he has
really talked about buying seg he said
they were buying Square no no I think I
think I think I think Square kills these
guys and makes them cry more the king
Chronicle coming soon to a theater near
you but but I think them working with
Sega because all Sega needs is a vehicle
Sega has the games but they don't have
the vehicle to get these games in front
of the marketplace Microsoft has the
vehicle right so whereas you know
they're working they're amicable to work
with uh Microsoft Sony and and Nintendo
said no we don't want your game pass
stuff over here we don't need you we
could do this we all right cool all
right buddy all right cool you don't
need us all right so they got the dude
that is working now I believe that this
partnership happens I believe that they
talk about that new Sonic game that they
was working on and I think it's going to
launch exclusively inside uh Game Pass
um and you know from there it'll go off
to other platforms I do believe also
youe of Pana news and all this stuff is
going to be launching inside Game Pass
we getting all that show the game no no
well I do believe they're going to say
the partnership they announce the
partnership and then later on you'll be
able to click like uh what what the
partnership entails later on but I do
believe that they announce a partnership
with Microsoft because I do believe that
this is the time when Martha and
Godzilla team up to kill KH I think I
think I I think this is it right here
cuz Okay listen Nintendo's gadora all
right now to to get gadora you g to have
to power you going to have to overpower
Microsoft Godzilla has to be overpowered
you saw what he did when he was
radiating right he had had the damn near
die and marur had to give him the life
to come back and get him so gadora we
know who he is Kong is an easier fight
he got legal battles all you got to do
is take the media out Kong is going to
die the med is helping K the humans are
interfering with right so we IGN we
trying to pump life into this dude so
much sh out Jes yeah shout out to y'all
y'all going down with the
ship and and I can't wait cuz y it's
going to be a point in time yall going
to watch your beloved Kong float
away and all I'm G to say is I told you
we got him so a lot of you Twitter D Li
P Liza Kong that's what people say in
the chat a lot of you dudes on uh on
Twitter this is where the [__] coming
y'all don't get my references and y'all
like Japanese IP is Godzilla Kong is
American all right when y'all watch the
movie y'all saw the the the humans
helping the hell out of Kong MH the
humans is
and all you media dudes helping the hell
out
of God Godzilla don't need no help all
he needs you to do is stop doing
underhanded stuff you saw Kong had to
get a knife right cuz he was underhanded
he's shyy that's Sony so listen I'm
telling you now Godzilla is Microsoft
and we gonna finish y'all off but Sega
is is marra and they're going to help us
out and we're going to get it done
together Atlas was a was a thing for a
while like I was I wasn't sure if Atlas
was ever going to put some games on on
Xbox now a lot of it going into game
pass it it's it's been interesting over
time seeing Sega and Xbox like making
partnership and having the post there'll
be like uh Xbox executive I think it was
uh was it Aaron Greenberg he was posting
something with Sega on his like story or
something like that so yeah yeah it
could be could the enemy of my enemy is
my
friend look you see what happen I mean
I'm excited you know obviously I'm a
Sega kid so clearly I have a bias here
you know um show shobi I mean I don't
want to get too crazy but I think you
know three got me thinking you know
super game for them to send this the
only thing super game makes sense
because we know it's a tangible thing we
know it's something they working on but
I don't know if that makes sense for
this stage I'm just curious like you
think it's too early yeah like part of
me thinks that like this this is the you
know I say the Casual Gamer but this is
like the masses so I don't know if
Partnerships and and those type of
announcement make sense to this audience
to me you got to kind of show them a
game you got to show them something that
kind of is actually happening so
obviously there's the you know rumors of
persona 6 maybe maybe too early um the
only thing that got me thinking and AD
me and you were talking about it is the
audience who they're they're selling
these you better show up too the one I
forgot again uh the lady I forgot her
name Corey
I actually looked that up they're
sending it to a variety of people but I
what I've noticed where the majority of
them always come to the center of is
jrpg jrpg and fighting well there's
there was there was a bunch of them I
looked up that's never played a fighting
game okay cool fair enough fair enough
so I guess good good cter my arum
because I would I saw it go to Max ailon
and I'm a huge Max Millian he's fgc
Community you know he is he is jrpg he
does love jrpg so do you think that it's
uh virtual Fighters part of me cuz NY
adct blew up my whole argument I didn't
know they send it to more other people
yeah I was like if Max ailon got it oh
it could be returned because they know
they heard Tekken is outside is the king
got to come back take his crown they may
have an unreal inine five virt five to
six or something cuz like part of me
feels it whatever it is it should be a
game as opposed to announcement but to
to three this point what if it's just
super game and this Partnership of all
these classic IP like yo this is what's
going on utilizing you know Azure
whatever so who knows but you know now
adct got me thinking if it's jpg I mean
who knows right it could be it's just
exciting to see them yeah it was it's
exciting to see them hype to tell people
yo you need to tune in so if Phil
retweeted oh really yeah I'm just I'm
just looking at some stuff right here
like my DMs be getting crazy like
yesterday I was off because I think I
got pink out
so I was I was I was squirting the pink
eye juic on my video was supposed to be
up yesterday and I didn't get a chance
to do it but I did record something so
that's going off for members but Phil
and people always sending me stuff that
Phil did or somebody did and and Phil
retweeted something and it's also he's
looking forward to the game awards so
he's gonna be there he's be there yeah
yeah it's it's just I think we're going
to be in for some real surprises but the
Sega Sega thing I really honestly think
what was interesting is how excited jez
is for the for for the Video Game Awards
well what's crazy is like if you guys
remember last year when Phil was sitting
in an audience and just seeing
PlayStation PlayStation PlayStation you
can see on his face and and right that
was right after the the CMA block
initially right so you had to come there
with that on like that was yeah that was
rough that timeline you know yeah I bet
you after that Phil was like I'm G see
you next year yeah see you next year
watch watch that's when you made Sith
Lord field that was the rise of Sith
Lord field because I I told
people
anytime person has to sit there and
endure humiliation and do it with a
smile on their face what you're doing is
planting seeds in order for a greater
comeback and I already saw what the dude
is built of right so he's like yeah soon
as this ABK I'm WIP the smile good kid
Bass man he's like how you
doing know you see Kanye West what the
Happ he
said he's pulling that scene with denzo
washt at the end of trading
day y'all see this y see when Kane we
smiling your
hair you guys know who you messing with
like on everything on everything he said
I'mma Crush all your dreams like all
your dreams that y'all having right now
I'm I'm glad back yeah oh man you going
to spend the I can't wait till the block
is spun I told you and see and I want y
to go back to last
IP where I said Xbox
propaganda is going to run rough shot
all over that show what you mean I
believe so I believe that you're going
to see all all all the sponsorships and
all the stuff is gonna be like for
Microsoft games they're gonna have all
the reveals for Microsoft games and
remember this is the first time Jeff
keigley said that he's not going to be
using that Monica World premiere yeah
yeah he did say that that is interesting
yeah so he's going to remove that
because that's going to get further like
to World premiere well yo let's stop him
let's stop I don't care what y'all do
you're not saving Kong you can try it
all your life right now this is where
marketing dollars matter this is when
your integrity comes in right so you
could want to say Kong all you like but
if somebody's giving you money to kill
Kong and you like money Congress goingon
to die so they're going to be buying
spots they're going to be putting games
there if you didn't want your game that
that Starfield let's say Starfield
because everybody think it's about
Starfield it's not about Starfield it's
about respect of the the games being
presented right let's say y'all want to
starf I guarantee you before the game
awards the the final game is announced
game of the year they're going to have a
starfell commercial okay guarantee there
we go you ready for guarante exclusive
they they're playing the seeds that they
already got for next year they're going
to put best remake oh they're finally
making that
what if what if they say we dropping to
dat right now inside new game plus a new
story line Starfield right G here we go
Shadow be
crazy ironically when like the Fallout 3
remake comes out and the obsidian one
comes out now Jeff key comes off stage
we're doing a category dedicated to just
remakes it it'll be interesting if take
the feedback from that in the indie game
thing but that's what I got on that I
didn't want to quickly combine the topic
of the um we had two premieres Fallout
TV series Halo TV series anybody got a
chance to see any of them any thoughts
three bit where you at you get a chance
to see either yeah I I've seen both uh
for the Fallout show I'm excited for it
because of Westworld I'm I'm a big
fan you know Jonathan Nolan and that
that team they they know how to create a
western
a different world where where uh you can
sort of step outside of the traditional
Western type show like they they add a
lot of sci-fi elements in that show
there's a lot of like you figuring out
the story as it goes along in with westw
World they just did a really good job so
that's why I'm I'm more hyped for
Fallout because of Who's involved with
it uh I mean it looks great in terms of
visuals and and they seem to get a
little bit of inspiration from before
rather than
Fallout um which some people are kind of
divided on but I don't mind it and uh
yeah it looks good in the Halo show how
we
feeling that's the
cheeks it was a deep pause like all
right let me explain this I I see the
Halo show differently from most people I
I treat it I treat it as a separate
thing I don't I don't treat it it has
nothing you do the incorrect way of
handling a show about a game okay got
you let the man speak they they said
it's a separate Universe I'm like all
right I'm I'm going treat it separate
you know so in its bubble if I'm not
comparing it to what I would like to see
from the books from the games it I I
enjoyed finally seeing a Spartan on the
screen kind of doing its thing that's
what I I enjoyed out of um so season two
it looks like they up the budget a
little bit we we'll see what they go
with the action and stuff like that uh I
mean I I love watching everything bad
good anime whatever I I watch it all
right so so I'll be there and we'll see
we'll see all right how did you rate
season one what was your rating there of
season one of Halo I'm just
curious uh like a seven okay all right
all right all right I got three popcorn
I got you three popcorns I'm saying oh
no Lord addict Fallout TV series trailer
Halo TV series trailer we was talking I
made you I like do not talk to me till
you watch trailer come back on the phone
yeah he bullied me in the
watch I I I feel like I might need
therapy over after that I was like we
can't talk till you watch it yeah I
mean when it comes down to I felt like
Fallout looked solid you know I got to
see more how they handle like the
Brotherhood is still they're a very big
faction what I saw it looks like they're
handling them very well but I thought
they were going to handle Halo well and
uh you know obviously that that didn't
really satisfied what I would have
preferred a Halo TV show to look like
you know maybe they'll get that better
in season too but you know Fallout I
thought they did the goal really nice
looked very official very authentic uh
the vibe of the world looked good what I
like too is like even though that you
know in the games they did go back
occasionally to the Vault that you came
out of it was never really the Center
focus of the games what I like is it
feels like there's going to be a C A
Center focus to some degree in terms of
story of this game of the of the show so
I like it I think they're going to do a
good job what I like the most
is media is trying more gaming stuff out
and it looks like they're they're
actually taking our feedback because I
feel like you know to this day it
doesn't matter what Sonic does it does
not matter if if if the movie starts
slipping which I feel like both of them
were amazing I'mma give them my money
because that director and the people
over there could have easily said we
don't care what you want it's going to
take us millions of dollars to redo
Sonic you this is your Sonic
deal with it they said nah they right
like went back they went back and they
they redid All of
the they redid All of the uh you know
the CGI when it come to that and I got
to respect it I got to respect it man
fair enough fair enough Lord King get a
chance to watch either trailer Fallout
TV series Halo yes
sir yes sir this is what y'all feed boy
y'all feared it man
and and I love it I love it I love it
when the trillion dollar company wake up
yeah y I don't know what y here vote for
that trillion dollar company Fork yall
told us I want I IP's other places like
dudes ain't spending their money money
spent right first season came out uh
that was made by
showtime and then you know Paramount
picked it up it was sitting on the show
for a minute and you could tell like
some of the CGI and stuff like that was
a little bit dated you know some of the
way to tell the narat good sections
there was good sections of Halo but it's
just as a as a whole I just I felt like
they butchered Master Chief like it's
just like to a degree like I felt he was
more like Master Chief at the end when
that scenario happened the entire show I
like of the show yeah well he was
supposed to do what he supposed to do
give you those little iconic moments but
you supposed to get laid sered at every
every corner well he's supposed to get
he supposed to get layers all right so
this is how I felt with den jiren and
the Mandalorian him taking off his
helmet and it went against Theo right I
felt like as as as a viewer they earned
that right because they they built up to
it and at the end of the that was that
was Pedro Pascal's crap but
but it was never written into the the
story regardless what it is it was still
done that way I don't care who I know
how passionate you feel about it but I
ain't talk when you talking
so I know how you feel maybe you should
we definitely would not have no no I
wasn't going to do that because I know
how you feel about it but this is how I
feel about it right now I gave season um
one a
three first of all I ain't like why you
argue with me I didn't I didn't No I
gave it a three out of five oh okay it's
a 70 it's a 70% can't get his ball right
so I didn't like the fact that you took
my man cheeks out my guy like for no
reason you Ain have to take his cheeks
out I don't I don't I don't I don't care
and you took your cheeks out I didn't
like that that was bad and then from
from the women that was watching it a
lot of y'all said those was bad
cheeks those cheeks y'all should have
gave cheeks wasn't three three popcorns
n gave y should have gave him a BBL
before y put him out there like that but
y put him out there with the sloppy
cheeks and then y thought that was
supposed to resonate with us like we
wasn't about that trying to get the
demographic yeah yo you know why listen
I'm confident in my sexuality right so
wifey was sitting there like what's
that I'm like yo why wasn't about it I'm
like yo so when you got Chris Evans
showing well he didn't take his cheeks
out but they talk about that's America's
butt you got to you got to have
America's butt type level if you
show level to the cheeks master master
chief Cheeks is at the bottom level of
that y' was trying to reach for
demographic and they saw like it's kind
of crazy that what king knows the levels
of man's butt
Che Oh Hey listen listen I'm comfortable
Within Myself to say you know a whack
butt when you see it do you stare do you
stare do you stare at
yourself cheeks well you know well you
know you they let you know if your
cheeks is is you know presentable levels
there levels that's how we going to
leave it like like like if girls ain't
commenting on your cheeks you got Master
cheeks
all right so that that'll let you know
not beefy cheeks clearly exactly exactly
super PA so I saw it and I was like yo
first I was like why they got the hammer
Dawn in in this cuz he saw and so I was
super intrigued with that what what the
hell is going on with that um then I saw
the Arbiter if y'all actually watched it
I rewound it a million times and I was
like that's the Arbiter that's the
Arbiter and they even have a scene where
he if y' y zoomed in they was like going
through his perspective you saw his
hands so they they doing a Halo uh two
or Halo 3 whichever hadit right so I'm
like oh snap they GNA do it I'm super
amped for that so they got me hyped and
the fact that Paramount has a larger
hand involved in this opposed to just
Showtime I think the production value is
going to be through the roof and just
seeing that um Apple TV and Paramount
has a deal where they're going to have
their streaming uh Services together
Apple wants in on this so they're going
to get their money you know from that so
it's just they're most watched right
like bro records with with Hal yeah they
did it did well it did well we can't lie
I mean and that was the lowbudget joint
so now this High budget joint you at
with the Flor where you at
dope okay now I know I saw a lot of you
misogynous incels oh I don't know I
never knew what an incel was until
somebody called it to me I was like I
was like I'm not insecure what the hell
they talk
about I was like what the hell you call
me that name for How You Gonna
disrespect me I'm not gonna be ignorant
in answer I gotta find out what you call
me first right so no it's not that all
right
so I I like where the direction is I
removed the character out the way right
because I'm not going to do that I'm
going to let it stand on his merits and
then I saw the cast that they
had and then I saw they started doing
parts of the game when they showed my
man with the no nose Walter Goin was
outside yeah Mr big teeth I call him Mr
B he got the big yo he had veneers
before he got like that
he got first
generation I'm kind of curious how the
um the the mutants and stuff are going
to look like the brutes what are those
things the power armor look crazy though
y you saw when it was walking down the
street yeah the power armor look
crazy I put that on the thumbnail man
was looking that that heat it was in the
ship was in the ship huge ropes that
kind that came through yeah okay and and
they had dog yeah they had dog meat you
saw dog
and dog was eating the roaches yo and
then the dude was just very casual like
you know you got to get used to this if
that's how you know you want to rock CU
be outside I'm like yo we are we are
here like three bit we are here they
finally respecting our medium of choice
remember when we was clowned and laughed
at never thought a video game movie
would reach this level yeah yeah and
it's not it's it's not corny like
remember the Mario movie the first Mario
movie where they you know it was was cor
do Bowser like that yeah right you saw
with the hit oh man so but now we're not
corny no more and they really going for
it and I love the fact that it looked
dope so and I love that it's Microsoft
own clear clear I got to make sure uh he
said we skipped uh accidentally missed
the Super Chat he Super Chat Cog knows
in his heart the answer is fortnite uh
we're not going to talk we not going to
talk about that
I he also said in the chat that he wants
to see what a death call looks like I
actually would really like to see that
too yeah salute did you get Robert Kelly
since you
bringing yeah $2 for for Rober well he
sent it to me on a DM I wanted to say
before I uh forgot to say uh so
joysticks after the
cheeks that's a question for S that's a
question some weird energy on him thank
you Robert Kell L gave that that's a s
question but uh I'll jump in if you got
your balls off k no I'm done yeah no
look it's it's exciting it's exciting to
see especially the Fallout project
because you know this is something you
can mess up like you you can mess this
up and I was like let me see how it I
think they had a a Vanity Fair article
before the trailer or something like
that where I saw the imagery and I'm
like okay the picture of the power suits
coming down yeah I said okay they got
the they got the vibe they got the look
let me see what they going to do HDR was
in place
yeah they said the show is um concurrent
to 76 said it's 25 years after the the
the bombs drop and it um we we we still
trying to figure out you know exactly
the timeline but I love that it's you
know kind of in the universe I love
seeing uh Todd Howard's name associated
with it again seeing the respect of the
law for the most part of course they're
going to have some creative Liberties
that they're going to take that's going
to be from the adaptations you know it's
giv me Vibes of it's giv me Last of Us
Vibes where the Creator was part of it
that's big for that's what it's given me
yeah that's big for me a couple people
went to him to that point Cog in that
same Variety article where there was
saying like Todd Howard was approached
multiple times of people trying to make
Fallout but they always placed it where
they they were just making a Fallout 3
Type movie or Fallout 4 he wants to kind
of do his own sort of thing with which
excited be inspired by yeah and and I
like the idea of TV series because you
need you can't pick put all this in one
movie there's always going to be context
that's how I feel I always like you know
the the idea of the series sometimes to
to Really flesh things out let things
develop and stuff like that so it looks
exciting now for Halo all right so um
y'all know like King I I was not a fan
of the first one shout out to Xbox I was
able to go to the premiere you know see
it um look I'm happy that flew you out
right they not fly me
out I just I just so so wait wait wait
wait you all right so you had special
seatings you saw I saw I saw episodes
one and two prior to release before the
general public so you got a chance to
see Kant in his debut yeah k outside
shout out to k bro he's back in his role
go support my brother his acting career
is really popping
off k I love you if you're listening you
do look like that brother I don't care
what you say but um
yeah it look my main
issue I I had to get over the The Mask
thing I still don't like it this is
their interpretation they're trying to
show emotion I get it you you can't show
emotion Co if the mask is on I get it
but I feel like it's such a definitive
direction to let the gamer know we ain't
doing what you want and I just struggled
I struggled I struggled with that yeah
no I I struggle that too he's taking off
his helmet in situations where there's a
battle B bullets is popping
ining that's you know where I I I
completely like threw out that show when
they were in that that law PL that
Lawless Place run around with the face
out talking to Bim W like oh don't get
me started but anyway we
we get the stra was outside but I'm
going let that joint but this is what I
will say towards the end for though I'm
not going to spoil for those who have
not watched season one but they do
something in relationship to Cortana and
him towards the very last two episode
and I said that's what I want moving
forward for the whole thing because that
was like that's how I envisioned him and
that's just me selfish car got admit it
that's how I like I thought those were
the two so I'm hopeful for the for the
next one I hope
um SPO no hopefully I'm not going to
spoil there was a certain antagonist
that was working with the Covenant I
hope I don't see that antagonist no more
I don't want to see Gaga I don't want
to you dead Lady
Gaga yo you
stupid not
cheeks the
best yo when they had all ship and then
she she released
them Dr lady gu i k you
stupid yo I'm about to pass out
anyway that was good that was good yeah
I I was not a fan and thus Master cheeks
was born and all that yeah nah so
hopefully season two hopefully we get
that what you said King it look like a
little Orbiter maybe you know between
now and the arrival at the Halo ring
more action heavy stay with the UNC I
like that and then you know flush out
the come we want to see you know more
the action and stuff like that so I'm
hopeful I thought the trailer looked
better I want to give it a shot but
Pablo please you know keep the mask on a
little bit more that's all get the mask
on a little bit age that's all that's
all but other than that I'm good anybody
got anything else before we move
on I'm sorry yeah it just comes down to
I I just want the Halo show to to stick
closer to to the The Source material the
KN gloser like I just don't understand
like the mindset when a director goes in
place is like take something as iconic
as like Master Chief he's like we taking
that helmet off 40 minutes into the
first episode like I just don't get and
first off I don't understand how
Microsoft let that rock either yeah it's
like that this is
literally arguably the O the one of the
biggest reasons you are even in the
console industry you yourself haven't
gave the the people who make that game
the I don't know if like they've ever
fought to remove his Sal but it's like
the people who made the game haven't
even un massive and you let some random
TV show do it like he still pissed off
he still pissed off I love
it world man camera going crazy too your
camera like I can't oh people are asking
about my bleach poster yeah yeah yeah
salute to the bleach no doubt but yeah
that's pretty much so I'm hopeful I'm
hopeful for season two adct when get the
super chat you move on yes sir I don't
even think there's a loss let me
get if I if I missed any super chats I
apologize like for some reason like it's
like it's not our fault this time we
actually have a section that shows all
the super chats and it's not showing all
of it it's literally something that they
created scroll through yeah so it is
what it is oh I see um Miguel evars two
pound Super Chat fill at the game awards
our new ABK CEO is Peter
Mo y y y y shoo wish for the Stars okay
so Lucius Augustus with the member chat
he's been a member for 27 months the
media suddenly forgetting what Phil has
stated many times now just seems
malicious how is it how is that not an
Xbox tax yeah you got that $5 per chat
from Champagne Xbox acting like a humble
bee they need to show out at the we read
that uh Miguel oh Xbox start you just
read that than yes Miguel yep got that U
we got a super chat from flame uh a
member trap from flame good afternoon I
just remember bunge snuck in pay to win
uh pack labeled capitalist crime on
Steam such a great a great Community
Support what what's that about I don't
know so no I know what he talking about
this is what me and Flame talking about
so basically Destiny tried to sneak in a
starter pack with Exotics and some other
stuff for new people $15 on the steam
store Community said oh really oh this
is what you're doing this is what you
think you going to get your % of Revenue
back and they had to delete that so the
community won yet again and they Under
Pressure man they Under Pressure uh R
read that too we got $2 for chat from uh
reread that uh $2 for chat from Nintendo
Dawn the otaku I think y'all skipped my
super chat too we got I I've read that
Super Chat no this is before yeah I let
me go ahead and read it just be on the
CU I did see it but I don't think I
don't I'm pretty sure I read it I'm
going to be real if you don't
okay but I'mma read it again so you
can't say I didn't contr
F all right so he said
um Cog I had a late patreon question
yeah I'm pretty sure I read that and
then he also said to fortnite game of
the generation it's undeniable I think I
read that and uh I believe that's that's
it okay cool we all
caught uh yes nice all right let's get
to it Undead labs this is me um oh no
Robert Kelly with the oh no jo stick
after the the cheeks yeah we read that
too cool all right stated of Decay 3
some information shout out to Idol sloth
in the realm kind of bringing this to
our attention so yeah looks like
potential new projects maybe so um yeah
they reply working on multiple projects
in addition to State of Decay 3
according to LinkedIn profile of an
former employee keep that in mind the
nature of these additional projects is
unclear with speculation ranging from
Storage of entitles in the State of
Decay Universe to Zombie Survival horror
action games uh rumors suggests that
development and release of State of
Decay 3 may be delay but no official
official information has been announced
and uh just to kind of dig further on it
shout out to game rant on this one um
yeah it said that um the this a idol
slof and rales can't pronounce his name
sorry may have discovered that they are
working on two at least two unreleased
games apart from State SK 3 which might
further explain why giz was developer
Coalition is helping develop the series
next installment because we do know
State Decay is going to be Unreal Engine
5 I believe so um yeah this this kind of
came across the line Floyd statement
didn't mention if the other projects on
that on their Labs is working on could
be new games or if it's acting as
support to other Xbox game developers
and uh some Gamers speculate the undead
LS projects are story-driven titles in
the State of Decay Universe other just
think it could be survival um action
Focus I I'll jump in this this is me um
as you know I'm a big fan of the lab I'm
a huge fan you know I think um addict
King they were like our first I would
say they would be our first like
developer Xbox game Studio I would say
interview or interaction when we kind of
first got in the game so it was right
around when stated dec2 dropped I
believe even one MPD that month we had
Richard fog on shout out to Jeff strain
and all the former members of the team
so I am very invested with this series
this series with the Xbox Live arcade
first one was to me like this Indie sens
the perade all that I I have love for
underl but I got to admit y'all out of
all of the studios lately I've been a
little worried with them cuz they've
been like super quiet I know we got the
um the CGI trailer of State de K 3 but
in my opinion that's a vertical slice I
mean it's what you're going for we like
that you going to do a glow up I like
that but um I just wanted to see what's
going on so when I hear this news again
we we don't we don't know for sure you
know again it is former employee but if
this is the case and they are working on
other projects I'm kind of excited about
that I'm kind of excited about that I'm
kind of um would love to see what else
they can do besides State of Decay you
know and um if it's still zombie stuff
but it's single play or related you know
that's fine but I I do want to see that
and I'm curious about what's going on
you know with the leadership so I wanted
to bring this to the realm how we
feeling about Undead Labs state of DEC 3
you know three bit where you at man how
you feel about that
trying to figure out how because you
guys know I I worked on Fable yes so
yeah trouble yeah yeah yeah don't get in
trouble brother I will I will I'll be
careful so um a lot of the developers uh
over at this different Studios they are
constantly one one thing I really liked
about my time on Xbox
just they're they are very collaborative
they're constantly helping out each
other with different expertise so like
Coalition for example they are geniuses
when it comes to um you know the Unreal
Engine and they are the best in the
business coming to that engine and I'll
say with like Undead Labs like I'm
excited uh with whatever they got going
on um they are deep deep in development
with with st of Decay and and um I
believe the last one was on Unreal
Engine four and this one is on five so
it's not too big of a a a difference
from from having to relearn an entirely
different engine and stuff like that but
I think they're at a a decent spot uh
they they got a bunch of new employees
um so yeah I'm I'm excited for and and
if they do uh another game inside of
that
Universe sort of when I watched the
State of Decay 3 trailer what I got out
of it was more story focused so I'm
wondering if like as they were
developing say the K3 they're just like
oh uh what if we want to do something
that is more story focused more linear
or or or something like that so that's
just my speculation like if they did
decide to do another uh State of Decay
game maybe it's going in that route so
that that's just my
thing M you're muted Co yeah sorry yeah
no I hear you um thank you for that
thank you for that no um I guess my
question for you three
is how do you internalize cuz what state
of decay has been out for a while we're
going say what 2017 I can't I can't
remember yeah when come out that seems
about right but I guess my question for
you is like what do you take when you
still see the consistent updates for two
I guess the way I internalized it was
like since you still updating two to
this day you need more time for am I am
I bugging for that or is it you think
it's like a live team still just doing
day-to-day stuff and they have enough
resources to still do you know these
potentially other projects in state of
the K3 I think they confirmed that uh
the updates are outsourced okay oh yeah
yeah yeah so uh if I if I was that team
yeah let's say it was internal it would
be a smaller team working on that that
wouldn't necessarily interfere with like
the main game every every Studio sort of
has their own development pipeline for
sure but uh I don't think it'll take too
much out of their if they wanted to keep
updating um uh State K to which they
should that's how you keep a live
service game alive right you just keep
updating it
um that that's something I feel like
PlayStation definitely needs to work
on is is having it's hard to do hard
it's hard though service is when you're
yeah it's not easy doing a live service
game you have to constant even if the
the games um I don't know their player
count is going down you still have to
support that game CU you never know what
could bring it back up so yeah like
Destiny right
now I mean yeah I mean Destiny 2 you
know a successful super successful game
M and the player counts going down but
guess what they still have to support it
they have like Hey we're going to come
out with another thing see what you guys
think people will jump back in they be
like oh okay okay I'm I'm liking this
new Direction that's what makes a live
service game successful that's what
something Xbox is really good at um so
yeah it's going to be cool to see what
they they come out with fair enough I
just want to get the super chat that I I
missed enigmatic dreams to our Super
Chat buy Square bring back Parasite Eve
someone needs to I remember Parasite Eve
y remember yeah I love that game that
was cool so adct man we we we stay at
Decay homies this is you know us four in
the whip you go in there you get all the
plague Hearts I wait on the outside I
got the engine running and we go to the
next spot I just make sure my tether
ain't too far away from
you you know I only issue with the game
I was like damn four player car but that
tent was killing me you know what I'm
saying but uh how you feeling about this
if this rumors are to be true multiple
projects on their
laps yeah I gotta I Gotta See
you know um State K3 before I'm hopeful
of being able to work on multiple
projects at once you know it's it's just
one of those things where it's I feel
like even though I enjoy State of Decay
too the the condition it came out in and
you know even throughout years the the
game the state of the game got better it
didn't launch like that at the at the
beginning so to me I still feel like
Undead Labs is in the proving
phase and and you know one thing that I
always criticize Xbox for is I
understand giving freedom to a point but
I feel like if a studio hasn't
necessarily delivered to to a high a
decent degree from the start cracking a
whip what we doing splitting the people
making the game as it is making multiple
projects I just personally don't see
that being good for the I talk it up to
the budget because when May first was
acquired like it it I I believe they
were working on sayk one they acquired
them that they were still working on two
so they're like a small team and and why
I'm kind of excited about it's because
their team is much more expanded but
yeah I I I agree I I get yeah and it's
not necessarily I don't think the studio
do uh doesn't deserve or deserves you
know a second or third team making other
projects but to me it's like you got to
prove that you're managed correctly and
you have the talent to do multiple
projects and as of right now from what
we saw State DEC to at launch sure it
got better uh but that was through
player feedback that was through their
Community helping them uh you know
deciding what was good what was bad
obviously that's how games and service
rolls but I need to see more from State
dek 3 I need to see you know uh what
have they done with the funds I know
they made a new studio they've hired
more people but if they're hiring more
people just go work on other projects
I don't know where that leads State of
Decay 3 sure the if there's if State of
Decay I don't know how many people works
for is part of Undead Labs right now
Undead Labs how many people 126 126
people yeah 126 and if they're working
on three
projects you know it could be a small
team like a six team working on one of
them to me I would rather them put all
their eggs into one basket you know get
get the Kinks out because obviously
they've expanded throughout the past
couple years and then once we really
once they you know get a good flow on
what's going on the management has a
good uh you know post on stuff then
expand I I I don't like the expanding
before you prove that you can make
sustainable games that don't come out of
buggy mess from the start uh that's just
my thing okay all right all right Lord
King State of Decay Undead labs
potential other projects what are your
what's your thought process I always
look at a studio and what they uh
ability to deliver the second project so
the first project uh it was it was okay
second project was vastly better uh in
forms of how they delivered it to us the
stuff that you was able to do in the
world that they did show right and the
budget that they did have so I expect
that same level of growth to be inside
uh
three I don't think that they had um I
think our problems is we we have a
messiah complex where we're looking for
the Messiah of Xbox to save Xbox and
that's the undo title that is put on
each and every new title that is on the
Microsoft platform so did the title live
up to better than the first title yes
did it live up to Messiah no so little
things like oh you you tethering and you
know we made a big deal out of certain
things this is a zombie apocalypse world
we want yall to be together right so I
think that kind of makes sense and then
the progression thing I think they had a
problem with the progression thing if I
go inside your world the progression
didn't carry over or something of that
nature and they work the Kings out of
that um now this game I don't think it's
going to look like the trailer oh okay I
think that's completely unrealistic for
anybody to believe that we've always
wanted it Final Fantasy 7 remake finally
looks like the trailers that we were
seeing when we first got the game so
many years ago right and it took all
that period of time and they dedicated
every freaking resource they had in
their world to get that game to look
like that and they're doing it in in
bized chunks this is a full flesh outout
game it's going to look adequate it's
gonna it's not and I don't want to use
those words Ade it's G to look good it's
gonna look good is going to play good is
going to be good now the ability to have
other uh games running it could be a
spinoff it could be that single player
game that they want to tell in that
world and to keep it like that so
everybody that was pissed off with that
um days gone and Sony abandoned that
franchise where it had promised maybe
this is their take on a single player
game no building no stuff like that and
they can do they can focus on Graphics
like a Allen wake type of thing they can
focus on getting a robo a robust engine
together and worrying about the zombies
coming so I I think we should give them
the benefit of the doubt of that because
yeah they're not a AAA Studio they're
doing doublea Studio stuff and that
their their work shows it so I think
they're able to do it um I'm not going
to tell them they can't do it and
they've shown nothing but growth from
the first title no I hear where you
going and again I'm going to give them
the benefit of Doubt on some level to
give them time to see what the actual
prod looks like I I do though feel like
we have to admit there was a lot lot of
restructuring at this place like you
know the head left there's a lot of
people you know left and I think strain
fogy and a couple other people and
peoples yeah these are peoples right now
granted you know strain is personal you
know we we we found that out as far as
the whole where he's based and all that
stuff so that seems like a logistical
thing you know kind of thing so I get
that but again I just want to see you
know what to addict's point I want to
see when they ready to show like what it
does look like and I'm hoping for Unreal
Engine five from cuz to me the game
needs a glow up in conjunction with all
the systems that it already so yeah we
give a sh but I am excited part me is
excited to say okay all right you got
all the stuff going so maybe there is a
budget being allocated to other things
as well and you getting a chance to
expand a bit so that's where I'm at and
and and and the promising part of it is
I don't think parent company will look
at your product and and give you more
funding to start another product if the
original product that you're working on
doesn't look like it's up to Snuff yeah
look I'm you had eight people make
grounded right yeah facts facts that's a
fact that's a fact I'm willing to give
him a chance we see but that's what I
got um Super Chat was one that was wild
funny I
PL Dem it oh Lord I didn't know we got
kid Cy as a
special yo n we ain't G we ain't gonna
go the K Cy route K Cy got his car blown
up we ain't gonna do that we a gonna do
that we doing cut in the witness
protection program now he got stuff that
he got to talk about oh man anything
else I'm adding just want to make sure
cuz I know we even oh yeah oh oh sh
check out
Dam months so do you guys think St the
K3 will come will drop in the next two
years yes I do oh she think all right so
by I think it'll be out in 2025 all
right all right yeah it's going to go up
against Wolverine I don't know if we
want to do that but okay yeah they want
to do that they think they going to get
a Spider-Man level I can't it's like I
said like if if stated k 2 would have at
least came out not broken and they
didn't have so many restructurings like
like think of like the the main person
left the person below him left the main
artist left like it's been drastic
changing in leadership
that that could be good but at the same
time we've seen throughout history that
sometimes developers need that one game
to get everyone in in the same tune and
to me when you haven't even dropped one
game with the new leadership on top of
the previous game coming out so buggy I
think it's a mistake to Branch out with
multiple games until you at least get
that one game as a whole as a unit I'm
trying to remember I don't remember
buggy maybe am I bugging I remember it
was bad it was bad was bad bu really not
for me okay I just remember the te I
remember the tell but I st K2 well see
here's the thing if you played by
yourself it was generally okay
was it Spiderman 2 buggy was it
Spider-Man it was on another level it
was on another level so it was worse
than Spider-Man 2 yeah it it was bad it
was see the thing is the moment you
joined with another person it was a rrap
like you fall through the map like it
was it was see look Lucy got said
launched it was really B okay cuz you
know what it was I remember when they
made the update to have an offline state
so that remember cuz you couldn't play
remember the the controversy was single
player you couldn't play offline you had
to play in the online State then they
added that you so when they added that I
went to that mode so I didn't exper okay
it makes sense see that that that's why
it was buggy because see Juggernaut
Edition fixed everything yeah it's just
like look like I'm not people in the
chat saying adct you're not you're
against creativity you know I'm just
against a a better product like like I
did you see like as much as grounded
isn't a game for me it was polished I
trust
obsidian right now I can't say I have
100% trust in Undead Labs until they
show me a product that at least is
functioning at launch now I love stated
K2 was a fun game but at the at the core
things they didn't really have a story
there was a lot of things that was that
was missing from State de k 2 and I just
want a better State Decay three that's
all I want fair enough no doubt hey oh
sorry uh that was uh three it was you oh
you good oh you good fine I thought uh
Cy had
something say uh the the delay low
situation like I was always on team
delayo my man my man
okay not me live with the 10 live with
the Thousand I don't know what currency
that is it's kind of cool seeing 3 bit
in multiple Xbox podcasts are you guys
talking about inviting people from other
regions we're always open the problem is
is we can't really move our day our time
because uh you know King has like a
weird uh everybody schedule uh you know
uh for the most part like 100 p.m. is is
kind of like a weird ideal yeah real
thing in general it so when you like
here now we will move depending on what
happens you know there are certain
scenarios but for the most part I'm
talking to people guests in Australia
that we want on and I'm like yo you GNA
have to get on 3 in the morning if you
want I can't jaese gu it's the time zone
sometimes too but yeah we do work with
people we all caught up yeah no doubt no
doubt and not last one this
is this is King I don't know where he's
going with this but we're going to see I
forgot what I picked this year you
picked the NC soft and Sony interactive
entertainment announced strategic
partnership and I believe this is very
mobile heavy and um yeah the two
companies CEOs T I cannot pronounce his
name t Tek Jin Kim oh let me get this
Super Chat Nintendo donu sent it to me
yeah it's in the directory at all if you
guys M us up doing us dirty and and and
I didn't read it send it to me on
Twitter and I will read it he said
obviously it's Nintendo related y'all
ain't have any Nintendo directors
especially for game uh for gameplay all
your triaa Studios only putting on
putting out 83 Metacritic games at their
best shame on you you know that man gave
us that thing just so he can roast us if
we didn't use Nintendo people when we
were making the game
shame on you what what what do they call
that when when you when you put guilt on
yourself and you're not supposed to do
it I forget now where like undercover
cops can't what is that called you you
can't incriminate self incriminate
yourself or something like that he
literally gave us a scenario to make us
get mad that we don't pick
we you know how go ENT TR ENT that's
what it was you want for everything we
wasn't going to pick none of
them you m games are cute yo don't do
them like that we we was doing some
adult I thought you wanted adult St my
bad adult your games are cute yo you
wilding out here yall cute I can't
anyway the two company CEOs of NC soft
and Jim Ryan still outside of siie have
met and jointly signed the partnership
under this partnership NC soft and S
will collaborate in various Global
business fields
including mobile and then they go on to
say the partnership with s is the
beginning of our efforts to build
various synergies utilizing both
companies core competencies technical
technological capabilities and expertise
said Kim um he added we will deliver a
new and enjoyable experience to our
audience across and Beyond genres and
regions Jim Ryan went on to say across
genres partnering with NC soft advances
our strategy to expand Beyond console
woo
you I get it now okay I see why you pick
this and broaden PlayStation's reach to
a wider audience
said third
party like SEI NC soft share SE and ncof
we share a similar Vision in creating
high quality impactful entertainment
experiences for players everywhere and
to get I see what you doing and together
we're excited to collaborate to push the
boundaries of Gaming further I
completely got why this is your topic
Lord King the floor is yours oh man a
partnership y'all been asking for but
never
wanted shout out to my man Jim Dan mov
Ryan yo he doing the best like before he
get out the door he making sure he
planting all the C4 all over
the to take down the building from
inside he keep text messaging Phil so
you wanted at the third structure
yo not the inform it that that's some 24
level remember
24 CTO what is it CTU has been
breached yo he he contacted Kevin Durant
to see how where he could buy his burner
phones
from yo this is this is the dopest thing
mobile push huh yo so now y'all on PC
shout out to Nix that's my heart you
didn't know who they were stop lying you
didn't know you just KN you just knew
they play but they became your favorite
at PlayStation Studio ridiculous I told
you I told you when they got though what
they was going to do right so now they
got the
partnership
soft MC
soft not MC soft not
MC can't yo y partner with MC
s that's wild that's
wild the wildest thing
the wildest thing about it is y said
what did they known for
mobile we going to push your stuff to
people that don't know about
y'all over here how we handle
it what you got to do is put your games
in an app right oh man and and when it
comes it it'll be an app in here oh man
y'all going to reach a greater audience
MC soft is going to take y to places
call
he's going he's going to expose y'all to
people y'all ain't never seen oh man
he's going to facilitate your
demise I can't I can't I am not gonna
lie they cap for the wildest Things but
ain't nobody cap for this you didn't see
the headlines for this yo so Jim put
this this ain't this ain't talking to
investors this ain't listening on a
conversation ain't got nothing to do
with you
oh no no no just got everything to do
you I mean to your point King I got it
I'll throw you a bone you know this is
this is an i article so be nice um Sonia
ADV announced a significant push into
Mobile gaming last year with the
formation of a PlayStation Studio's
mobile division so they just did that
and the um acquisition the acquisition
of savage game studios that's kind of
funny to develop to develop Chang that
right yeah to develop a triple A Mobile
Live service on game and Sony had
announced that releasing games on new
platforms was a new key part of its
business strategy so so they so so they
they acquired Savage games M and hooked
up with MC
salt so it's MC s l
savage it's Savage they got with the
Savage and the soft I can't I can't oh
yeah yeah so now they're neon Koy that's
what
neony they change it yeah yeah M y'all
see where y'all going why y'all not
talking about y'all going third party
even though y already third party you
want to see the YouTube you want to see
the articles for this yeah y'all go
mobile baby like this has this is
directly talking to y'all this ain't no
the investors meet in no Summit that
y'all wasn't invited partnership y'all
was invited to this partnership It's
Already Done y'all got a phone he
talking directly to you so
soon in a not too distant future y'all
will be able to play God of War rid and
Ro right
here right here in this
puppy soon this will be your gaming
device and y'all didn't have no money
down like no money down y'all iside but
they gonna find a way to monetize you
but I wanted to bring this to the realm
because I found it very conspicuous that
nobody else was talking about the fact
that Sony is making a hard push
M and and the fact that Microsoft is
getting a mobile storefront up and
running I saw people talking about that
and how that was facilitating the way
for Microsoft to go third
party without the same energy here's the
same energy here's where Xbox taxes
real y'all went out and got MC soft and
partnered with him y'all picked up
Savage y'all got your team together
y'all said all we need is a little bit
of soft right
now we can really take this Mar it
over money at right so now you're going
to reach a whole new demographic I just
wanted to bring this to the realm to
find out if y'all thought that Sony was
doing what I thought they was doing
because other outlets ain't talking
about them you know picking up MC soft
and Savage and getting
busy l three vit uh your thoughts I mean
it it point you know the announcement
was made the Strategic partnership about
uh NC soft and Son yeah I
mean too much too much here's the thing
here's the thing so when when uh Jim
Ryan was basically saying like we want
to start pushing for games as a service
games yes uh we want to make like what
was it 12 16 something G the service
game I agreed I thought that was a good
good move for Sony they they can't
necessarily spend on the same level as
Microsoft so what are what's something
you can do yeah what can you do in the
meantime to sort of uh caveat because a
lot of their Studios aren't making the
like live service type games they making
single player based experiences so what
what what can we do to basically have
reoccurring Revenue rather than start to
focus more so on console sales hardare
sales I hate the remember so based on
that logic that would imply to King's
Point that the console sales to them by
itself is not sufficient for their
long-term plans or what we consider a
company's Northstar right because you
wouldn't partner right to your point
with a a lead I mean I heard NC soft
they've been around for years they've
been yeah they've been doing things for
years so you would and announced this is
actually announced what was crazy about
it I forgot to this was announced from
the Sony Entertainment website
interactive.com website this is Sony
promoting yeah this is not a third party
this is this is literally Sony letting
them know they're excited about this
part I'm sorry to interrupt continue no
no yeah so so I agreed with with Jim
Ryan taking that direction just based on
the games that they have available the
games that are in pipeline mostly single
player based uh them as a company really
focusing on hardware sales as opposed to
their services um as so much like
compared to Microsoft right so when they
announced like Hey we're going to start
canceling some I was like oh okay
okay so what what are they going to do
now right if you're going to start like
lessening that gamees a service push um
what can you do in the meantime to sort
of caveat and and be like oh I I can
maybe start investing in another
ecosystem which is mobile so to me this
makes sense it does make sense it is
funny to see when when King put it I
didn't even think about it yeah I didn't
think I was like when I'm reading it I'm
like oh I get it I get what he yeah yeah
as as as I was reading it and as you
were reading I was like okay
we see what he it is defense this is not
KNN this is from Sony this is not King
News Network this is from Sony
themselves Sony interactive.com go we
start working with Sony lately we just
signed a partnership with them you're
ridiculous I think that partnership is
not going anywhere anymore after the
what else what else do do you guys think
they will do like for for example with
mobile games it's not just a smaller
version of God of War I I think it could
lead to scaming I I think it could be I
mean yeah I think I was um speaking to
Colin about it and um another thing I I
believe
Horizon there there's I don't know if
there's MMO rumors of like MMO potential
because I think this company they make
City of Heroes like a very they're MMO
heavy yeah very MMO heavy and career so
to me it's like they're looking at
career they're looking at the potential
there Mobile's great and again I know
people struggle with this stuff but this
is where the money's at this is Sony is
eyeing this they are preparing
themselves to potentially where gaming
could go and again not saying they're
completely abandoning console I'm not
saying that but they want a piece of
that P kid they want a piece of that P
but the conso is not enough they I mean
they sold a lot and they still and they
still in the red ridiculous I mean they
they said multiple times and it's not
Fanboy were they said that a lot of
people aren't buying their games that
the most their most sold game is Call of
Duty it's third party games that's that
that's not a fan no I mean that's a fact
yo y three B who ow Call of
Duty you're ridiculous the most so game
on your platform you don't own we own it
thank you for funding our
bank continue I love this I love it
that's all I was gonna say where they're
headed right now the
mobile The Rock The Rock jumping off the
ro oh man
for
the so like that's that's where they're
headed mobile like they they are
basically seeing the road map of where
PlayStation is headed they're saying
what is profitable they're realizing for
for a while I was like is the direction
of just focusing on Hardware Sales is
that the right direction I didn't have
an opinion either way I was like is uh
is focusing on Hardware Sales the best
move or is it focusing more so on
software like I for a while I was like
which way is the way that of the future
because you with hardware sales if
you're just focusing on like hardware
and your in your games and your first
party you get uh you get the the
messaging like oh this is premium you
get the message that oh um they're
they're respecting me as a customer this
is my personal device this is you know
within my ecosystem but uh you are also
closing that off to other poten
potential people who are maybe they want
maybe want to dip their water and see if
that's what they actually want to invest
in um so with Xbox's approach sort of
opening up their ecosystem it allows
people to just try things like like do I
really want to play Halo oh it's free to
play oh it's on Game Pass etc etc so um
I think they're starting to realize that
I think they're starting to realize like
whoa uh mobile is way bigger than the
console market we've seen that maybe not
a lot of people are purchasing our first
party games they more so purchasing
third party right so how do we start
opening up our
ecosystem uh and and and that's mobile
so yeah no me good point good point adct
I don't know if you got a chance to see
this what's your thoughts on NC soft
partnership with Sony looks like a m uh
push you know any thoughts on this
direction from uh Sony I don't care
about nothing mobile yeah play not for
you what about Final Fantasy you get
that Final Fantasy
mobile as long as is that's that's okay
but like for the most part I don't
really play anything mobile I tried like
a Final Fantasy game like early like
three or four years ago that was on
mobile and it just didn't VI I think the
most mobile game that ever vied with me
was like a Marvel Ultimate Alliance game
that like a turn base game like I really
enjoyed that game but dangerous I I
think the reason I don't like mobile
games a whole lot is because I invested
money into that and yeah oh it's
dangerous they they they shut down the
servers so it's just like at least with
console games that does happen but I
feel like there's so many mobile games
being made it's literally a gamble which
one you want to put your time and effort
and money into yeah because at any time
they can get shut down uh you know and
that it's like I said that happens in
console games but I feel like there's a
lot of mobile games that they just throw
out there to The Ether hoping it catch
and if it doesn't they just shut that
down like 6 months did that to me and I
remember that no it's it's a good point
I mean it it's definitely there's a wave
aspect to it right and but we do see
like Call of Duty mobile is crazy out
here Diablo m is crazy out here
obviously Candy Crush and was it son
Sony I mean Sega has was it roio I think
was it Ang Birds I believe but um so
there are successes that are so
lucrative that they you could tell like
they they want to get a part of it and
again you know we're talking about the
simplified term King is hustling
backwards right if you just saying
selling to the same customer the same
work you know what I'm saying and you
not and that's cool you're the best on
your block that's cool you know what I'm
saying but if we're looking at the
states and the Burrows and what
everybody's really moving out here and
the money that's really being made out
here they want a piece of that and and
and that's going to happen I'm not going
to say is a super extreme pivot but the
fact that they announced this
partnership was very very key to me and
the fact that they had a Playstation
Mobile division now like they they are
intent on like Jim Ryan always said you
know we feel these IP should be
Blockbusters way bigger than what they
currently are so to me I have to
internalize that you are not satisfied
when the MPD comes a free bit and you're
saying they're not enough I'm not saying
that but I'm saying that they are not
satisfied with the revenue from these
great IPS that they feel should be
bigger right so now found don't buy
games what you I they go to
people party unless they were lying they
were saying in the coure case like Call
of Duty was funding third party games
are funding their first part it
surprised me how much of a over now I
will agree three bit it surprised me how
much Reliance they had on Call of Duty
it surprised me that they never Envision
the Future No One and today the fact no
one could Envision the future where we
thought Microsoft was going to acire ABK
let's be real right
about out out just sitting here I caught
an epiphany I caught the wildest
Epiphany all right so we already saw in
the transcripts that Phil and and and
and um Jim and Bobby KK they would play
golf right yes yes yes we already we
already got this right so what if Phil
was sitting there the whole time they
playing golf and still just listening
and you know Jim you Jim get a couple
you know what I'm saying and then they
playing he like Man Without You Balby
we'll be in the dust so said aha I got
him oh you
overheard Mayweather and everybody go
out and they be thinking Mayweather is
drinking no he don't be drinking he be
drinking SSA water he be drinking he be
having a vodka and tonic but he don't
and you know that guy to be acting like
he drunk y'all crazy but he's not really
drunk he's just trying to see how y'all
slip up and see what can come out yall
slipped up Jim write notes WR not he
took that he was like yeah Bobby likes
money we got that they relying on this m
take that and make them crumble and
Bobby had a scandal and slipped on a
banana pill that wasn't intended to
happen it was serendipitous in how
things happen you know what I'm saying
but I you I'm I'm just saying though yo
yo chill adct hold on man hold on I'm
listening to this and I'm
like he
knew he was the Inside Man all the time
it was Sano the whole time oh not s oh
man what's funny man there looking at
I'm looking at the topics the go I'm I'm
sitting there looking at the topic and
I'm thinking for the first
time out I'm going be out of this sucker
before four we was at four
lit add it was sambino the whole
time shout out to the PlayStation
controller in the library but there we
have it so B we'll monitor it we'll see
what happens you Sony the mobile space
but good topic king um adic in super
chats before we get out or should I read
the poll first let me double check I
don't think I saw any but there might
have been like one or
two uh let me just uh TX th x138 with a
$2 Super Chat a stady game game without
bill just like
fortnite hilarious
mhm uh and I think talking about the
special guest one so I think we were
caught up No Doubt new ILP poll with the
rumors of Sega having a presence at the
game awards which of these do you think
would have the biggest impact on the
show choices are a Sega super game
projects he came up with this before
three bit guy here I'm proud proud he
said that b Persona 6 adct c k a new
virtual Fighters the king is back or D I
don't care big Sonic movie is outside
go check it out go watch what's going on
and again salute three bit my brother
thank you for being patient we going to
get you in the room the right way this
is just the first introduction you know
what I'm saying roll out the red carpet
proper but I appreciate you holding us
down where can to find people find you
what you got going on Sir yeah uh people
could find me on Twitter at I3 bit uh my
YouTube also I3 bit I appreciate you
guys inviting me to the realm you guys
chemistry as a family it's special man
Community sees what you do you're
respected you guys be killing it so I am
honored be invited to the realm love
everybody here and uh I'll see you guys
on the the next one I'm I'm on fsp of
course where you at where can they find
you though yeah yeah so
CP fsp what does fsp stand for I don't
know what's my next my next oh FS fun
speculation fun specul okay all right
all right see if we get a link or
something I'm on those on Monday on Mavs
channel right sh out the M um Tuesdays
we do fun pot where we talk about like
uh comics and things going on in DC
and yeah and then Wednesdays I'm I'm
starting to do U my own my own shows so
um take a take a Gand there okay we got
we got the channel what what's the do we
got a channel yet or we wait we in
development the album not out yet we
waiting for the album okay okay cool let
me know when the release date and then
we going to put that bad boy out there
you no doubt I respect it now can't say
bad boy
you feel it's legal action it's legal
action yeah we we not trying to get
associated with that no I appreciate you
brother album coming out no appreciate
brother appreciate your Insight you know
super well versed and um a lot of times
people tag me a lot of you know tweets
you say and it's very insightful giving
additional perspective from a developer
perspective and also you know showing
some balance as far as some Nuance to
certain conversations and I really
really appreciate you brother you're
doing your thing we will have you back
in the realm Royal carpet the the
correct way but I appreciate you holding
us down you already know and of course
Lord addict where can I find people find
you you got power in the building he's
got the power you can find me on Twitter
at Lord addict
IOP uh you can find me on my YouTube
channel at gaming addict U I'm going to
be probably cutting back the videos
probably uh middle of this month
probably from like CU I post like five a
week so I probably go down like three a
week I wanted to have some
videos I'll probably post the rest of
the week and then like the news unless
something happens newswise which is
unlikely for the most part after the
Video Game Awards uh the whole industry
is going to go dark until January uh so
that's cool uh you know appreciate every
coming through we had up to like 1100 in
here definitely hit that like button you
know if you guys enjoyed the content and
uh once again uh you know I next year I
will be starting a streaming Channel
called the addicts Arena I'm putting
that in the comment section below I'm
going to be streaming you know more
games doing you know uh talk show stuff
over there most of stuff like that uh
yes I will be streaming Nintendo gam so
Metro and then because I figured I I I
want to stream I just don't have an
outlet so I got to build one nice uh but
definitely uh go go go to that sub to
him man I think you guys will enjoy that
uh once again three bit thanks for
coming on the show man uh I think I I
think I podcasted with you once I just
can't remember whose podcast it was yeah
I can't remember I I jump
around
around did we get um I'm sorry Nintendo
on he got another one the king the
Godzilla King trailer too just dropped
no oh fin out Super Chat they really
trying to save Kong King how many times
they going to learn so a new trailer
Godzilla Kong 2 just dropped literally
yeah his cousin just came out the bushes
he trying to kill Kong boy they got Kong
in the in the earth he got to get out
he's like go H Bo a legend to I King did
you see this new Godzilla trailer I'm
about to see it bro all right yeah
everybody's talking about it so it's on
it's on graphic God I got you don't
worry about it we had a little technical
difficulty what we're doing we will get
that right next week Lord King where can
to find people find you what you got
going on first and foremost yo I want to
say thank you for three bit coming
through you gave me the biggest shot I
picked my head up boy yo I I'm going to
be talking about that for a minute cuz I
was
like your phone y yo you had me cuz
remember I'm wearing Shades so my joint
is fuzzy half the time until I put on my
glasses my glasses right so I'm like
yo I say and it was genuine it wasn't no
B it was straight genuine all right so
I'm G give you that I was like ah they
did not put that in the
notes coming in with the surprise acting
like we have
notes we have notes we we we say what we
going to talk about anyway um shout out
to mm shout out to uh our writer of the
month our subscriber of the month shout
out to our editor Ed of the month
sticking around also filling in I want
everybody to you know you know say happy
anniversary to Cog I know joy stick and
you guys y upset right now but your side
Boos and that's how you're gonna stay
ain't nothing gonna change that
um love your side boost status you get
Valentine's gift after I'm done
Valentine's Day I am done um you can cat
me on Xbox front line boom right
there where you can see if you thought I
was messy
ha I'm definitely going to be messy the
whole week through I drop videos every
day I didn't drop a video yesterday um
because I thought I had pink
eye we got to we got to protect that
yeah the kid wasn't feeling well uh also
had D Ryan figh and all that of stuff
remember stuff is going up so I want to
give a shout out we hit 5K yo czy salute
um is it's a beautiful thing uh I want
to thank everybody that was there we
give we gave away the first statue but
the guy got to give me his information
so I can send it yes he can send um oh
he he actually hit me up on Twitter so
we'll talk about that later all right so
he has to hit me up um and then uh you
know we got a 5k we're going to do that
raffle the calling feature is dope so
it's calling throughout the week I do
videos throughout the week on Fridays is
the live show 6:30 p.m. Eastern Standard
time we do the call show we talk about
some topics and we go into the calling I
want I listen I see a lot of you guys
will always try to get my attention and
y'all always talk about y'all some Kings
y some this and Y some that and oh you
want to call out into a debate me you
don't never show up be like you make
yeah you know who I'm talking about yeah
all you do is with all that hot talk in
your mouths but when the king call you
out y'all don't show up you disappear
and I want y'all to be more than what
y'all say y'all
I want y'all to I want y'all to actually
grab your kees and step up to the
microphone and talk your talk and walk
your walk so I could just you know back
y'all down put your back in the corner
that's what I do cuz remember I'm the
one that got rid of all your generals me
solo by myself in the street mopping you
and putting youall to the side so um
y'all can't save Kong as y can see from
the next trailer that dropped and I want
y'all to know how topical I am I'm the
fortnite of
this I was talking about Kong and
Godzilla before this trailer drop you
understand I'm current I'm current I can
flip I can change it y'all worried about
holding line y'all better worry about
holding Kong's heartbeat because he's
about to go down oh man salute Kies
absolutely messy today and I got to
watch that trailer you got to watch that
trailer we got to see what's going on
again thank you three thank you mm thank
you Lord gaming that net laa floor the
entire team really appreciate the
contribution that's all I got everybody
enjoy your son let's add got anything
for me we good
um I we trying to run you know they get
to get you before they get you let me
find out who we're saying thank you one
bad mother appreciate
you is that the trailer is that it what
trailer no he watching
trailers he watching trailers he
watching tra all right so I think we're
going to send everyone to we
going where we going where we going uh
we got a couple
options we got Professor Broman I
remember uh Cassie plays Cassis plays
The Young Turks he said Cassie out here
what you doing we political Channel Cass
I don't know and then game on uh
probably send you to Game On yeah gin as
yeah no there it's ASA
his go in there I Ray man I Ray No Doubt
and we are out of here everybody enjoy
your Sunday
[Music]
PE